we want to go back to the first day that
you quote unquote quit Hollywood you can
remember that day do you remember some
of the emotions that you were feeling
Yes actually so at this time I was an
actor right and it was just acting
and it was the plan a I don't need a
plan B either I'm gonna make it or
that's it right a very naive of me but
it it got me a long way so what happened
was I was called out to this audition
and I drove from Orange County and I
drove to this to this casting I forget
where it was but it was somewhere by the
Universal Studios if I remember
and I remember having this inner
dialogue with myself and I was like all
right I'm gonna go to this casting this
is going to determine and I was like
talking to God I was like this is the
one either either I I booked this and
something happens or I'm done
and the sign on this day couldn't have
been any clearer to me that at this
moment in life the universe was like
this is just not right for you so I go
to the lot I said hey I'm here for a
casting I forget what it was for
and
they're like there is no casting
I said okay so I checked my email the
day is Right everything is right
last minute the casting director changed
the audition date to another day
so that was like that that was as clear
as it as it was and I was like okay I
got it I got the sign I'm done and
in that moment I said kind of get
goosebumps now talking about it but in
that moment I was like all right well
this isn't for me and there was so much
time and effort where for that span
of like going to auditions I was almost
a Power Ranger
um always getting callbacks
and
never quite getting that defining role
or or anything that could catapult me
and mind you at the time
this is what no one ever tells you I was
in the one percent of earners
in you know for like a good two to three
year stretch
but what you see on TV the Brad Pitt's
the you know Leonardo's they're the one
percent of the one percent
so the one percent of being a working
actor
what is that at the time it was like
twelve thousand dollars a year or
something like that and for a couple
years I was averaging like a solid like
40 000. I was doing like for me single
guy no wife no kid
I was like okay I'm doing something
but in that moment when I drove all that
way casting they they it did a few
things to me where
a part of me almost like
broke
because it the I've never had a signal
in my life just be so clear
it was just like
okay this isn't for you at this time so
when that happened and that switched
happened I took a couple years off
but
something inside of me
I didn't see the change that I wanted to
see so when I first went out to
Hollywood this was straight out of high
school no family no friends no money
nothing like that I just left
and
I told myself I would be the Asian Will
Smith right and obviously when you go
somewhere you do something you want to
be the the first you that's always the
answer you hear from somebody oh I'm the
first me but you're always inspired by
someone or something and that's what
kind of fuels you to do something
so at the time it was Will Smith and I
was like I want that career
for myself
in hindsight
I wasn't ready for it I thought I was I
thought I had the looks I thought I had
the personality I thought I had the
charm
but I wasn't ready for it I was never a
good auditioner
uh I would spend all this time you know
going over lines non-stop that you go
into the room and you think about the
line so much that it deteriorates the
performance compared to just performing
and
in hindsight when I think about
what I did wrong because at the time you
almost feel when you see colleagues that
you've worked with and you see them
doing well and you see them doing all
these big shows that you auditioned for
and you didn't get and you see them
doing you know movies like Shazam and
all this stuff you
naturally you feel a certain way
but as you get older you be and you
mature as a human being
you become happy for their success
because that their success doesn't take
away from your success so when someone
succeeds you should always look at it
from a place of
well if they can do that I can do that
and use that as an inspiration to kind
of Rocket you to do whatever it is that
you want to do
you were 18 when you flew to Los Angeles
from where Georgia from Georgia okay so
you even though you've been raised
somewhere else yeah so I was born and
raised in Hawaii
um but you know my goal was always to
get out of the island so my mom at the
time lived in Georgia so after my
freshman year in uh Hawaii which was the
school was Chao it's K Al k-e-a-a-u High
School uh I moved to Georgia and we
thought well in Hawaii there's a saying
like oh if you want to better your life
you go to the mainland
so my mom was in Georgia so I stayed
with my mom for my sophomore year to my
senior year
and fun there's a funny story about how
this led to me moving to LA
so when I was
Junior Senior High School my best friend
and I were into tuner cars our whole
group was in the tuna cars
and on this night I don't even know if I
should be talking about this but it's
fine on this night uh we were driving
and he had like a a souped-up MX6 had a
klze motor swap and all this stuff and
then I had an MX3 nothing fancy but we
were driving side by side on the main
road and we were like talking because at
this age I was like really hyper I was
like hey what's up man we were just
talking and a cop pulled us over
uh and we got tickets for street racing
so my license got suspended
so I couldn't drive I forget what the
length was I don't know if it was six
months or a year I just I don't remember
but we couldn't drive
and upset because that's your freedom
right being able to drive is your
freedom as a teenager
uh my mom so all of this is is really
thanks to my mom because
she heard on the radio that there was
this acting school coming and the
school's name is John Roberts Powers at
the time I don't know what they're doing
now but at the time that's what it was
called and they were at the radio and
there was this big convention center and
everyone brought their kids and it was
just packed it was packed I didn't want
to go I was like I'm not going to this
stupid acting thing because it's not
anything it wasn't with me as a kid I
never thought to myself oh I want to be
an actor I want to be a director I
didn't care right I was playing
basketball
um but she forced me to go so we sat
down I don't know if it was the director
or the rep or whoever it was at this
event but he asked hey who can do this
commercial for me right now
and for some reason I just raised in my
hand because I thought it was dumb I was
like yeah I can do it's not a problem so
he said okay I want you to pretend it's
a baby diaper commercial and you're
putting the diaper on the baby or
whatever it was I'm surprised I remember
that
um and I did it no hesitation I just did
it I was like oh you know and and I
guess he was so impressed that I was
able to do it that he invited me to
their Atlanta location
um and he paid for everything so he paid
for the teachers he paid and my mom
would drive me in the mornings really
early like five or six a.m wait all for
the eight four to eight hours that we
were there and then drive back right so
she would wait and we did that for a
year and after that year there was a a
Las Vegas event called ipop at the time
and I uh they paid for me to go to Vegas
to go to the event and everything so
then I got an agent out there at the
time
obviously you're I'm naive at the time I
don't know anything I don't I'm like oh
I got an agent right from from Georgia
at the time it's not like now where all
the Productions are moving to Atlanta
but you just don't know you think I have
an agent I'm gonna be something
so
at this Crux in my life not having any
family members that graduated from
college not having anyone that's
successful financially so they're at
that point there's no one to look to
it was like this is my golden ticket
this is how I'm gonna build a life right
um so once I got the agent and I
graduated high school I sold my rate I
had like this nice Boombox stereo I sold
it for a couple hundred bucks and then I
flew to to California
and that is how I ended up in California
where did you end up uh at the time it
was
I believe it's Hollywood Boulevard
Hollywood Boulevard and then I moved to
Granada Hills
and then Granada Hills I just kind of
went South the whole time like every
because
I got fired uh I was a waiter at Olive
Garden and I got fired because I saw a
pretty girl there was a guy at the table
with her and another girl and I'm I'm
assuming the guy liked the girl and I
asked for her number while I was waiting
their table and uh he complained and
then I got fired so when I got fired
everything kind of
crumbled because that was the way of how
I made money and she said something
sorry he said yeah he said something and
being 18 with no skill set right it's
like how else do you get a job because
you have to balance between making it to
auditions
and working so at that point it was like
place to place renting rooms couch
surfing living in the car going here
going here just kind of doing that whole
thing for a long time sorry did they did
you bring him extra breadsticks I mean
to make just just appease him yeah you
know what I I didn't know oh so yeah
there was no flirting between them there
was nothing I just and being young sure
you're 18. I was 18. and I I just saw a
pretty girl and I was just like hey
what's up YouTube what's your name sure
um whereas in hindsight
it was well worth it right because I met
my wife and had our son and that's how
life turned out so it was well worth it
but in that moment it led to a lot of
struggling which I can't really blame it
on that because I have to take
responsibility I'm the one that
shouldn't have asked for a phone number
while working so it all comes back to
being my fault but that that that's the
Crux of how I ended up in Los Angeles
so do you mind if I ask how long were
you living in the car couch surfing so
though that was probably like a good
year that was probably like a good year
because what happens is and along the
way I had a lot of people help me out
right you don't make it living on couch
surfing living in your car and stuff you
don't make it on your own and there's
people that tip their head in here and
there whether it was you know someone
giving you 10 20 bucks whether someone
letting you stay on the couch for a
night I used to park my car into the
neighborhoods to go to sleep
so
and there was a there was a couple girls
at the time that uh that let me stay at
their place and shower because you know
I didn't have money for a gym membership
to go shower at the gym so you know
every couple weeks or so often they
would let me kind of stay for a night
and then that was it and you kind of
just navigate and find your way and the
way it kind of worked I never had credit
I didn't have anyone that had good
credit I didn't have anyone that had
money so I couldn't say hey let's get
this apartment or this house
um
but what I did have was charm
and just perseverance so anytime I would
get that big commercial check right or
and this was the time I don't know what
it's like now because I haven't been in
any commercials recently but like at the
time when I did like a McDonald's
commercial or anything like that you
know I got like 20 30 000 for one day of
work that would last me
six seven eight months of rent and gas
and insurance to kind of make it to the
next gig right whereas now in hindsight
I'm like man if I got a 40 000 check
like that I would just put it down on a
down payment on a house rent out all the
rooms and then they have them pay for my
mortgage and then that way you can focus
on something else because your roof is
taken care of so no
sure but it took it took a while for you
to get that kind of financial literacy
yes yeah and a lot of hard hard breaks
oh no I was gonna say yeah that all that
all came because of my wife so
my wife is much better with finances and
she's more successful than I am
and when I met my wife first day I met
her I told her hey we're getting married
and I'm giving you a boy we got married
and I gave her a boy oh wow and what she
told me there's a few things she told me
she said you're going to get life
insurance
right so I got life insurance and you're
gonna go back to school so I went back
to school for I.T
and now
my day job I'm in I.T I'm a network
engineer
and that's how I made money so the by
her forcing me to go back to school I
took a loan on half and she paid for the
other half so really she invested in me
as her life partner
by doing that and getting that stability
I was very lucky because I had somebody
again help me along the way to become
the man that I am today it didn't just
happen by myself like yeah I put in the
effort you know studying and making sure
I show up and get things done but it was
because my wife said I know you're
capable of more so you're gonna do more
she was the wind to my sale right as
cheesy as that sounds so by me going
back to school getting that stability
now having a skill set
I'm able to create and do so much more
and and help Inspire other people
because I'm not worrying about where
food's coming from I'm not worried about
the roof over my head I'm not worried
about you know
life not not to say that there isn't
things to worry about but I'm just not
worried about life because I know
whether I'm working for somebody whether
I'm working for myself whether I get
fired tomorrow I have a skill set and
with that skill set you'll always be
able to make money to support your
family so with that stability as a
filmmaker and actor director producer
writer
you're able to create like never before
because you're not worried about the
struggles of life
so back to the earlier question when I
was an actor just a pure actor in in
Hollywood struggling
you couldn't really get as good as you
want to be because so much of your focus
is where am I sleeping tonight how am I
going to get food right and these are my
Ralph's chicken tenders with mac and
cheese days or that was my meal right
so once you're able to take care of the
core of living as a human being
you're able to fully Express Yourself
as a creator
that's excellent and a good point too is
when you have these quote unquote Gypsy
jobs here in La someone else's term that
I've I've stolen so Gypsy jobs which are
you know hey we need you to do this
promotion or whatever for a week that's
great and they can pay well but then you
have to look for new work and you're
always your time is spent looking for
work as well so same with acting did you
have a backup plan when you came to La
no and that in hindsight
that's probably one of the things I
would have done different
um obviously the life that we're on is
the life that we're on and the things
that happen you cannot change but if I
could still have the life that I had
today but make some adjustments along
the way so that Journey was uh not as
turbulent
I would have had a plan B
and even now being in the position that
I'm in now
filmmaking is a hobby until it generates
more than my career
and I tell anybody it's like hey if you
want this to be your number one then it
has to generate more than your current
number one because as a human being as a
father as a husband you have a
responsibility to your family to provide
so because I have a family I'm not 18 or
19 and if I were to give any advice to
someone that's 18 or 19 I'd say hey have
your plan B
and have your plan a and do that in
parallel
because eventually they can do this but
if you're if what you want to do is a
doesn't pan out then at least your B is
going to take care of you through life
because whether you succeed or whether
you don't succeed time is going to go
anyways
so you might as well pursue it but
pursue it the right way I see a lot of
times where younger people
and I was one of them
that say
I don't need a plan B I'm going to make
it on plan A
but what happens when you spend 10 12 15
years doing something and it doesn't
happen
right time goes by fast at one moment
you're 18 then you're 25 then you're 30
then you're 35 and it's like okay well
what do I do well
if you rock your plan a let's say this
is Hollywood right whether it's a writer
producer any anything creative this is
plan a plan B is uh you're a dental
assistant your real estate agent you're
a mechanic it doesn't matter if you do
this like this eventually
if this pans out and you give enough
water to this seed hopefully you can do
this right and this can now be the main
thing that you're doing but
a lot of times where artists tend to go
wrong
is they don't see the show business of
it we all want to create and not talk
numbers but if something doesn't do well
then you can't sustain it
the business of Hollywood itself
wouldn't sustain itself if it doesn't
make money
so
I say all that to say this
if you want to be a producer a writer
director
there's two things
make sure you have food on your table so
if you're living with your parents stay
with them as long as you can because
life is just easier
and to just do it
just do it doesn't matter if it's a
small project big project big budget no
budget just do it because you're going
to get better as time goes on but if you
don't do it and you expect somebody to
just give you that handout but you're on
level zero there's no way you can get to
level 10 without going through one
through nine
why do you say that you weren't what you
thought was quote unquote good enough
to make it at that time
I don't think I was disciplined enough
there's something that comes with
discipline
when you when you have
the struggle and then you have the lack
of knowledge you're winging it
and in life
you can't get anywhere with winging it
there's some things you can get into or
get access to that you're not supposed
to by winging it but if you want to
succeed
I say look at whoever it is and dissect
backwards and create a plan because the
more that you have a plan the more
likely you are to succeed so if your
plan is
hey
um I want to be an Uber driver then you
know like okay I have to download this
app I have to send this information I
have to get qualified I have to go
through their courses and then I have to
go uh and then I get qualified to be an
Uber driver and then I pick up people
and drop them off okay so there was a
plan there so if you want to make it as
an actor
what's the plan oh I'm just going to
show up well
for the the lottery person that may work
but for the majority of us you have to
ask yourself okay outside of everybody
wanting to be Brad Pitt right let's just
take that off the table for a second
okay what kind of career do you want to
have
do you want to have a career as a
commercial actor do you want to have a
career as a theatrical actor a movie TV
okay well who's the casting director for
your favorite shows what are they
looking for
um what's the look what's the tone right
if you're looking to go into movies
where and I say all that because as an
actor you're really taking anything that
comes to you right if you're in that
circuit any audition commercial TV film
you're just you just you're so hungry
and so desperate for a job that you'll
take anything Union non-union it doesn't
matter but if you're able to create a
plan
the tunnel the light becomes so much
clearer
so for example
and this this isn't the greatest example
but I had an agent in LA right I mean
not La Atlanta right now I'm agentless
no agent no manager no anything I kind
of bypassed all of that but I had an
agent in Atlanta and I knew that I
wasn't a good client to have
because I turned down 95 of the
auditions that came in
because I had the stability of a career
I didn't need the jobs when you don't
need the jobs you become picky
so now by having a plan and a goal I
knew the roles that I wanted to play I
knew the projects that I wanted to be a
part of were projects that sounded
interesting to what I like and just
interesting in general I no longer
needed to just apply and be accepted to
anything out there because I didn't need
the money from the job albeit whether
it's a commercial or an acting job
because I had a career over here
there's power and strength in that
because now there is no desperation
there is no
um hey let's just send Jason out to
audition for this gas station guy like
how does that benefit me in my career
okay I have one line you can give that
to anybody you don't have to audition
for you can just give it to anybody you
went to a PA on set hey can you say this
line yeah absolutely right
so when you have a plan and you're able
to just kind of go from step one to two
to three to four the likelihood of you
getting there
sooner
is a lot greater
how many times do you think you heard
the word no while you were in Los
Angeles
every time I would say my my booking
rate was probably I would if I'm going
to be fair I would say probably about
three to five percent
so out of every hundred I booked maybe
three to five
um
which in hindsight isn't bad and I would
say about 85 percent of it 85 of the
time I would get callbacks
and those are the most crushing
because I'd rather just get a no than to
get your hope up that you could get it
they called you back like Power Rangers
I went to like five auditions and you
could possibly get it and then they're
like nah no I you know I'd prefer to
just you know cut me off at the door but
yeah I would say
no is probably the greatest thing
to
make you as a human being stronger
because when you realize that every no
is just closer yes they're just little
things that come and come go out the way
to get to that yes
you welcome the nose I welcome noves
it's okay because I'm gonna talk to the
next guy I'm gonna talk to the next guy
I'm gonna talk to the next guy until I
get the yes
that's what's changed with being a
filmmaker compared to wanting to be an
actor
if you're someone out there that's a
creative
you spend so much time wanting to get on
set
whether it's background work because
that's how I started I started going
background work
um a one-liner
maybe a day player
if you look back on it and you spend all
those years just to get on set what
happens if you would have created a plan
to create your own set
how would that have turned out and
create the project and the role that you
want to be a part of that you want to
see and then be in a position to give
other people opportunities
in all of my films majority of the
actors are first time second time actors
with not a lot of credits and I make
sure that if I say hey do you want to be
a part of this project and they say yes
and let's say in the script I only have
one line for them I'll make sure to go
back and write two three four five lines
so they really feel like they were a
part of the project and not just there
to kind of make a cameo
right so
I just think that as a creative it's
important to
create the
films
that you want to see and you want to be
a part of compared to wearing so much
about trying to get on set
I think it can change the dynamic for a
lot of people because if you think about
it social media has changed everything
for people our age
that were born in the 70s 80s like yeah
we grew up with the Hollywood star for
us it's the Stars right
for the newer generation it's the social
media influencers they're the Stars
so
you can create your star
at home in Kentucky
it doesn't matter where you are you can
become a star you push record and you do
something every day and just be
consistent with it and I would challenge
anybody I'm not good at this I don't do
it but I would challenge anybody if you
put on your calendar right now say I
want to be a influencer right and for
365 days without missing a day you post
something about something I can
guarantee you that account that's at
zero in a year if you did it every day
without missing a day
that you will be way further than you
are today now the issue with that is
comes back to responsibility to the
human self how many people are going to
stick to that every day and be
disciplined because there's power and
discipline to do that every single day
not make excuses and not miss it
because I don't do it every day I'm
quite frankly I because I grew up in
that era which I think is the best ERA
for films 80s 90s like hands down the
best ERA for films and entertainment
um that's what I enjoy doing so that's
what I spend my time doing I'm not into
social media as much as I should be
because that's where everything is now
um
yeah I would say if you want to make it
you want to do it
start with your phone start at home
create it because then you get enough of
a following they're going to come to you
anyways
in hindsight do you wish you had left
Los Angeles earlier
yes and no
I want to say no because that led me to
meeting my wife which
then we had our son
but yes because
it's not even leaving La sooner it's
creating sooner
I we I don't want to say wish because
wish makes it seem like you're looking
at some third entity to do something for
you
it would have been nice to
create
sooner
create the roles
that I wanted to see that I wanted to be
a part of sooner
that would have been nice and I think
that would have changed a lot because
for anybody out there
once you do your first film
whatever you thought was hard whatever
you thought was difficult whatever you
thought was impossible is gone
because when you can complete it once
you can complete it twice then each time
you do it it becomes easier and easier
so when I did the first film by no means
is it an Oscar film is it is it well
written because I'm not the best writer
I don't put commas in periods where they
should be I kind of just write and this
is the story and this is what we're
gonna do I don't do 10 drafts I do maybe
two just to kind of check it
once you get that first film out you
learn where you make mistakes
you learn the focal length that you'd
like to shoot it and that you don't like
to shoot at you kind of learn your style
right so getting that first film Out is
more important for you as a human being
and as a Creator to let yourself know
like I can do this and I can do it and
get better every single day and I can
keep creating
than it is for you to create a
masterpiece of a film because I'd rather
have
10 average 5 Star films then to have one
masterpiece and the reason for that is
because if you think of the economy of
actors writers producers grips Pas the
whole economy of making one film if I'm
able to do 10 that are average films I
gave them a lifeline
of 10. I gave actors and actresses the
opportunity to be a part of 10 films
compared to one
and you live and you grow and you in in
as time goes on
when you make films it's now an
experience because you've made them
compared to watching them when you watch
a film or you watch a TV show there's
this ah there's this magic to it that
you're like oh wow that would be great
then when you make it and you start
making it and you start making film one
film two TV series web series
it's not that the magic leaves the magic
of the lens changes
where now
you're not looking for someone to give
you an opportunity
you're able to give other people
opportunities
and I can tell you from my films
how many actors
have started creating their own projects
and that in itself is so rewarding
because by them looking at you and
seeing you do it
they look at themselves and say well if
he can do it with that I can do it too
and that is so rewarding and that I
think is a game changer
what's your advice for let's say an 18
year old graduated high school comes to
LA with really no no plan but also
they're leaving a situation where they
didn't have a choice maybe how do they
keep themselves creative how do they
keep themselves safe okay so that's
that's a really good question I think
that
stay away from anything that looks easy
uh
stay away from
hey why don't you come live with me
where is that coming from what's the
ulterior alternative motor uh what is
the ulterior motive there
um
I would say go back to school
even if it's worth even if you have to
take that loan
because you'll make that back and I
don't say go back to school for film go
back to school for something that you
know makes money
because having that those funds they're
going to help you create they're going
to help you be
a better version of yourself
so
stay away from drugs stay away from
parties stay away from situations where
you are not your coherent self
and write two goals
write your goal on okay
how do I get to where I want to be
whether that's a writer on the fox lot
whether that's a producer or director
okay
who can I shadow
or who can I contact to Mentor me
because they'll give you insight and
information that'll get you there a lot
sooner than you trying to figure it out
um
how can I stay grounded and true to
myself
you know
a lot of times you hear people
talk about
oh
this person
you know sold their soul or anything
like that right something crazy
but I think what really happens is
when you're young and you don't have a
choice and you're just trying to survive
think you do things that as you get
older and you grow as a person
that you weren't proud of
and I think that as you get older it
sits on your conscious and it eats you
and I think that's more of the Soldier's
Soul than anything else
and I would say to stay strong to who
you are at the core as a human being
because when I was 18 and I was out here
there were opportunities whereas like
hey yeah comes
right
and I never took up those opportunities
but it kept my conscience so clean
and the objective of and the goal of
what I was trying to do so
strong that even though I quit
acting after
15 years
or it was like 12 12 to 15 years I don't
remember exactly but even though I quit
at that audition
I didn't it didn't take away the fire of
wanting to be a part of something great
and the magic of
film
is that you're able to inspire
someone at home
whether they're in India or they're in
Georgia
you're able to
spread that magic
to someone else
you're able to
live forever within that space of time
so
when you create a film and you star in
it you co-star in it and you're on that
screen
it's almost like a legacy capture piece
because your kids your grandkids will
always be able to look at you in that
time and space and say look at my dad or
my granddad that was him
and I think that alone is such a magical
thing
about film and I know I kind of went off
from the advice I would give the 18 year
old but I that goes back to me saying
stay true to yourself
don't compromise who you are that
doesn't mean that you you don't have to
bend and you have to give because in any
even marriage or relationship and a
career is kind of like a relationship
there's a give and a take
but you don't compromise in your core
values as a human being in your Pursuit
of anything
why have you been able to create the
roles and the projects you want in
Atlanta but not so much in Hollywood
price
um I think that
so in Hollywood and I noticed it even
when I flew in
it's like there's there's this go go go
there's this hustle hustle hustle
struggle struggle struggle survive
survive survive you feel that energy
here
and in Atlanta it's a lot easier to get
locations it's a lot easier to get
collaborative people
because
a lot of times it's just the effort the
aligned effort I don't even call work
work anymore it's just a lined effort
right so when you have that aligned
effort with multiple people
you're able to get something that's a
lot more magical a lot of times you hear
from people that say Hey if you're going
to make an indie film make it in one
location right
and I'm completely against that and the
only reason why I'm against that is
because you still have to make the film
interesting to the viewer and if you
only have one location there's only so
much you can do not to say that there
hasn't been successful films in one
location but when you're an indie
filmmaker you're trying to maximize
production value and how can you
maximize production value on a stringed
budget
in Georgia you're able to get these
locations that you would never unless
you knew the owner of this place or
something or he was an uncle you would
never be able to get
so that is probably why it's so much
easier to create in Georgia
and and it's cleaner there too isn't it
like it looks from from the stuff that I
was seeing on your channel like it just
looks so clean and all the places look
so nice like San Fernando Valley for
anyone who hasn't come here you really
feel the struggle here yeah and and
that's just you know minutes away from
Hollywood but there is that's funny as
an outsider for just a little bit seeing
that perspective because when you live
in it day in and day out you don't even
realize it yeah absolutely and the thing
is it's not to say that Atlanta the city
doesn't have its struggle because it
does but you know the the state of
Georgia is very family oriented small
businesses right so if you kind of if
you're into those two things Georgia
will be great now you're going to have
your little pockets that's real country
but if you're not into those pockets and
you're kind of like in the Metro areas
and stuff it's it's a beautiful place to
live
but there's still
it's a lot easier for you to get your
project done in Georgia and I would
assume for any filmmaker in Kansas Idaho
Chicago any place in Georgia outside of
LA and New York I would assume it's so
much easier for you to use what you have
use the places that you visit frequently
where people know your face and if
you're able to write your story around
that kind of stuff because if you're an
indie filmmaker and your thought process
I know my thought process is I'm not
looking to sell this to somebody to hope
that somebody else gives them a yes to
then hope that somebody else gives them
a yes to go make this project I write
within what I know that I can accomplish
to go shoot
so I don't have a backlog of 10 15 20
scripts I write shoot right shoot right
shoot
that if you're in another state and
you're like man I need to get to
Hollywood or I need to get to Atlanta I
want to get into the industry
you can start the industry where you are
because all it takes
is One Financial successful hit and the
reason why I say Financial
is because nobody cares how good your
movie is if it's not financially
successful because it's a business so if
you can create something that's
financially successful
and get a return
Where You Are
then you can create
your own solar system
of Hollywood Where You Are for my films
I use the same actors the same people
they don't even audition anymore
for all of the roles I'll call them up
hey do you want to play this role yeah
okay cool we're gonna do it and then
that's I I really wanted the the Adam
Sandler
thing I really wanted to to have this
core group of actors that we become
family and we work on all of the same
projects together because one thing that
I know about Indie filmmaking
and this is really advice to any
filmmaker
energy
cohesive energy amongst people
is a lot more valuable and you'll get a
better product than having somebody
that's extremely talented could be the
best actor best writer best anything
best director
but if their energy is not cohesive with
the rest of the crew and cast
then one drop of toxic and you know a
gallon of water it's still poisonous
so
energy is important why did you schedule
the production on Sundays
so
I knew that
I was free
and I was able to focus on weekends to
shoot and I knew that majority of the
time
actors aren't doing anything on weekends
so I thought to myself hey we can either
make movies on weekends while we're
watching Netflix from our couch
or
we can do nothing and watch Netflix on
our couch so that's why you know
weekends is the most beneficial because
I work like everyone else we work during
the week you know we have rent to pay
and bills to pay but on the weekends
it's like that's fun time you can either
relax or create and I think a lot of
actors can
agree with this
you feel alive like I know for me I I
come alive when I'm filming when I'm on
set like it it's a feeling like no other
it's almost like a
I don't want to say hi because I don't
do drugs and I never have but it's
almost like a high I would say for the
lack of better words
I come alive when I perform
and I know other actors for this way
because you can see the Sparkle turn on
when it's like action you see the
sparkle when they see themselves on the
screen you see the sparkle
you're able to take the audience to
another world right and
it's so important because majority of
the actors on my films
first time actors maybe they've done
like a student film or a short film but
they're not they don't have these heavy
credits you have like one or two that
have a lot of credits but for a lot of
them it's their first time
so by being able to give them that
experience to let them know like hey you
already did one movie you can audition
and you can do other movies and you can
make it happen because you've already
did it
you have you're boosting other people as
well you're giving other people
opportunities to Showcase what they
really want to do and you're letting
them know like hey this is a safe space
you have the creative freedom to talk
yeah the creative freedom to say
whatever you want you have the creative
freedom to like a line or not like a
line and change it and play it how you
want to play it you have that freedom
you don't have to feel nervous
um and if you look on the phones a lot
of times you're you're not really able
to tell that it's a first time actor or
a second time actor because
that comfortability right acting is
about being comfortable just when
there's action you're comfortable and
you're going to get two different
responses from actors one that's not
comfortable
they're going to rush through their
lines
oh my God what is that huh what
comfortable actor oh my God
what is that
okay that's great I like that tape right
because
that's what we were trying to convey
if you can allow someone to be
comfortable you're able to get a better
performance and I think that
by a shooting on the weekends
you're already relaxed
and then by shooting with the same
people the same actors same crew
there's familiarity
there's no pressure
by you having the freedom as a Creator
or creative to do whatever you want now
you know like hey it doesn't matter if
you mess up lines
I will sometimes purposely mess up lines
to let everyone know like it's okay
we're just gonna push record again and
we're gonna go
and
I think that
by shooting on weekends you're able to
get a lot more collaborative people on
board with your projects
because they're not doing anything on
those weekends anyways for the most part
plus two it's in Atlanta and I know
there's a lot of Productions but not as
much as La so do you think people feel
too this an excitement that they're part
of a Film Production
absolutely I mean
you know how do you climb the stairs
without taking steps
right you have to take steps and
once you're able to get your feet wet
you're able to swim in the pool
and it's important to join your theater
group your do student films short films
commercials because you're getting
experience points like a lot of times
I think people see people on TV and they
say I can do that it's no problem that's
easy
for some people oh it is easy for some
people but for most people
you know how much work it takes just to
be comfortable in front of the camera
and have a hundred people looking at you
sometimes it's not about you being able
to do it sometimes it's about you
trusting in yourself enough and being
comfortable enough to do it
and sometimes that's the barrier so I
used to be really bad at auditions even
though I would get a lot of callbacks
and stuff I used to just not perform as
good as I could but anytime I booked a
film or a commercial or anything
I did fantastic when it was go time and
I don't know what that circuitry was if
I could if I could take that go time and
put it in auditions I probably would
book a lot more
but for some reason I didn't view the
audition
as the job
and I think if you view the audition as
the job
you'll win more
and you'll do more
as a creative
how did you start over in Atlanta so I
was working an I.T job as a network
engineer
and I was sitting there
and this is right before covet so this
was like 2019.
uh that this happened and I was looking
at the landscape mind you at this point
I I kind of quit Hollywood for a while I
was an audition and wasn't doing
anything and I was looking at the
landscape and I still did not see what I
wanted to see what my goal was when I
went out there I didn't see it and just
for some insight what the goal was
um if I break it down further than like
the Asian Will Smith it was really
seeing a leading Asian guy
and a non-asian role so what that means
is
if you see someone like myself
but it there is no kung fu
there is no okay this is about an Asian
family in Malaysia there's nothing it's
just like hey that guy
uh just so happens to be Asian there is
no Asian story we don't own a liquor
store there's no laundromat there's no
Kung Fu there's no sidekick it's just oh
he's the love interest and he just
happens to be Asian
when you create stories like that it
becomes powerful because now it's it's
just normal it's just normal right
you're not you're not highlighting the
fact that this person's Asian they're
just
a human being playing a role so because
I didn't witness that enough right and
you have your hits right you have your
shangshi Marvel film fantastic but the
title is shangshi
it's a martial arts film
that takes place
where there's a lot of Asians then you
have something else like uh crazy Rich
Asians the title is Asians dealing with
an Asian family so of course you're
going to cast Asians now mind you these
films are fantastic films
but in order to separate that Gap
really for all ethnicities
you have to play regular roles right and
you can't
Force right and a lot of times today we
see forced you can't force something
that's already established
and what I mean by that is
if this franchise has a history
and this character and a fan base along
with that history
and this character like let's say Iron
Man right Robert Downey Jr that's
everyone's Iron Man Iron Man Has looked
like Iron Man
since the beginning right
if you now put
uh
another racist Iron Man
it's not going to work
because of the history associated with
that character
you have to create new
characters you have to create new
stories as whatever that race is or
whatever you want to be
that's a lot easier to digest from a fan
base because it's new
than it is to
swap somebody out because it's trending
today because now you're alienating
the 50 60 years of fans that have
purchased those comic books that have
read those stories that have fallen in
love with these characters for instance
I'm a big anime guy
I love Dragon Ball Z if I ever get the
opportunity to direct or be a part of
any Dragon Ball Z live action film I
swear I would do it justice
but we all know as anime fans
what these characters look like right
and here is where it's it's that fine
line
so because we all know we've been with
these characters for people that are my
age we've been with these characters for
25 years
this is what we we like love and we are
into
if you change that
or
or you gender swap it or anything
for us fans who are Die Hard who will go
watch anything related to that you've
now alienated us
for for whatever reason now if you want
to race swap it gender swap it or
anything like that create a new story
create a new comic create new characters
create new story lines create a new
world right that's the beauty of film
you can create anything and put anybody
in any role
so with my films when I write
they're just new story lines and a lot
of times I put myself in the leading
role because my goal is to break that
barrier and the way I do that is
they have like if you think of something
like a like four Amigos or like my a
film we just wrapped it where it's in
post now it's called pizza boy brick
it has nothing to do with race I just so
happen to be an Asian guy in the film
but because it has nothing to do with
race you don't see that it's just like
oh he's just playing this character
that's how you break the wall down not
by forcing it like oh okay hey guys
today we're gonna put an Asian guy in
this role
like if you put
me as black panther that's not gonna
work no one's gonna look at that and say
okay yes yes we want no nobody wants
that I don't even want that that doesn't
work so I think that's where creating
your own story and originality is
extremely powerful and if you want to
see change in the Dynamics of Hollywood
in American Cinema then you as the
writer as the filmmaker you have to be
that change you have to create that
change if you're Indian Asian black like
it doesn't matter you have to write the
story from your perspective because you
can't expect somebody that's not your
race to write you as that leading guy
because they don't know your perspective
they know their perspective so if you
want to create change and you want to be
a part of change and you're sitting
there and you're like oh why haven't
they done that don't make excuses go
create the change because even if I
break one layer in my career the next
person will come and break two layers
and then before you know it there's a
trail
what about everything everywhere all at
once
how is that for a beautiful film
beautiful storyline in terms of the
stereotypes
there's so with something like that
there is the exception right
people are going to create what they
know
and what they love
right
so
the creators of that they made the
little John video
I forget what the music video was but it
had like an Asian dude that was dancing
crazy and it was breaking through the
floors in the wall and like their style
is very very creative
that's fine it's a it's fine to make
time skip in martial arts action that's
fine because that's what we've seen
as far as what we're used to from let's
say someone that's Asian
but if you want to continue to keep
pushing that boundary then we have to be
the love interest
we have to be the guy that saves the day
right we have to do these things and not
have it tied to our lineage
so if you think of something like
let's say
um
it wouldn't work but like let's say
House of dragons
right if the King was an Asian guy
but it had nothing to do
with him protecting an Asian
state or or property or you know land
and the way he got that power was he
killed the king
that's powerful
because it has nothing to do with him
being Asian he just so happens to be the
guy that killed the king and now he's
the king and everyone fears him so
they're not gonna
approach him right
that's where the little minute changes
happen
and and to your point it really takes
creators
of different ethnic groups to create
because only you can create from your
voice your experience
and your perspective no one else can do
that for you
how do you think it is for people to say
well yeah there's there's all sorts of
you know whatever there's RR there's um
you know the Shahs of Sunset there's
crazy Rich Asians there's all these
these shows out there but it it's it's
only like within one world yes so it
kind of just like exists but but it's
not there's no diversity it's just all
one of each kind and and here's the
thing America is like the Melting Pot of
the world right seeing every race is
normal whether you're uh at the grocery
store grabbing a bite to eat we all
blend we're all a bunch of everything
right
so
in order for
anyone to see
anything that represents them on screen
they have to create it you can't expect
someone else to create
your story your pain
if they're not like you it's just it
they can't because their lens is
different
right
so when you mention
Triple R
fantastic film by the way I loved it
yeah
um
but that's in all encompassing
film
with its own ethnicity Associated to
that film
and that's fine because you're going to
always have those
but that's not an American film
when you're talking about American
Cinema and you hear in the news you hear
from all these creatives like oh this
person you know doesn't like this or
this person hates this or why can't this
person be this
how about all the noise stop and how
about action take over and how about
people start writing start creating
start filming start casting start
producing instead of talking talking
talking for someone else to go do that
if you're constantly talking for someone
else to do it
then it's going to take a lot longer for
it to ever get done if it ever gets done
so we've seen
strides I would say nowadays it's kind
of like a lot of times it's forced
that's why it doesn't work because it's
forced nothing forced works even when
your parents say hey go do the dishes
right now like you reluctantly go to do
them dishes compared to
you know hey get these dishes done
I'm gonna make sure that you know
whatever it is that you're trying to
accomplish the iPod or iPad or whatever
that you wanted you do these dishes
enough time without me having to tell
you I'm going to make sure I get that
for you okay cool now not that you have
to come to some kind of agreement with
your kid but
it's a lot easier than having to force
them to go do something because now they
don't want to do it
so it sounds like if something
is too much within its stereotype then
it's it feels like it's too patronizing
maybe yes because now you're only seeing
blue
when in fact we live in a rainbow right
when you see too much of one color
that's that's what it is right it's it's
like oh okay yeah that makes sense
that's that kind of film
but if you're trying to blend everything
then
it's important for those new stories to
flourish those new filmmakers to direct
and create and to cast you know
for those roles because if not then why
would it change if the business has been
successful for a hundred years and it's
been financially
um
uh in the positive then why would they
change that why would they go and take a
risk if you think about it right even
big actors that are established they
have to go screen test sometimes they
have to audition right
if they have to do that and they are
proven what makes you think that they're
going to go with an unknown
different ethnic group
for this row and take a risk on you and
invest 50 to 100 million dollars for you
to go and hopefully bring a return
that's not going to happen or if it is
it's super rare but if you go create
your own story and you go and make that
film and it becomes successful now
there's a track record
for you to level up
and have the opportunity
to expand that Vision in that voice
you know how there's the Bechtel test
the tests certain things about how women
are portrayed or or how they're seen
through the lens do you do that with
your films where it's like okay I don't
know if I want to do an ethnic
stereotype I know this person checks
this box but I don't want them to fit
that role so I don't check any boxes
um
my films are super
diverse but it's not on purpose
I get the best people really energy wise
and they all are very talented
but I get people that I like and when we
collaborate on a project
there is no okay I'm putting this person
in this role because they're this that
doesn't exist on any of my projects and
when we film I give everyone the
creative freedom to do whatever they
want I don't care what they say I don't
care how they say it I don't care how
they play it just know that if in this
scene it's important to mention a glass
of water
right because somewhere else later in
the film a glass of water something
happens with that glass of water then
okay hey I don't I don't care how you
get here just say something about the
glass of water
everyone has the freedom to play it
however they want so there is no
stereotype because you're playing it
however you see it
um and I think that's important
so when I cast outside of great energy
um
I personally just don't see
really anything outside of that's
another human being so any role in any
film movie that I make anybody can play
it
anybody can play any role and it's fine
and sometimes on any films you'll
Shuffle like hey you know what last
minute like okay look look you go here
you go okay cool okay great and that's
kind of what's worked for me
do you think you would be as effective
in Atlanta now had you not spent those
15 years in Los Angeles uh no I think
that pain
which is just your memories and feelings
that you attach to those memories
if you're able to conquer that
and let that go
you're able to to grow into a better
version of yourself so those struggles
of being in LA
those wins of being in LA
uh getting into those casting rooms
seeing the casting directors booking
jobs missing out on jobs in hindsight it
was such a A Life Lesson in school of
hey you want to make it in this industry
that's what you're going to go through
you're going to go through 10 no's to
get that yes you're going to go through
50 notes to get that yes yes yes and
then you're gonna go through another 60
notes to get a yes
it's so important because you're able to
adjust and calibrate your mental and
your mental is so important because
if you can be grateful for getting the
opportunity to say some words to
somebody that can say yes or no to you
and you change that perspective so the
perspective I used to have was I already
did commercials I already did movies uh
here's my pictures they know what I
sound like and look like they should
just hire me right that was my
perspective at the time and I felt like
I was too good like yeah they should
hire me like you know I can do this
but there's a thousand other people that
have done work more work than you look
just as attractive or whatever they're
looking for as you that's why they're
having you come in to read so when you
change that perspective from I'm too
good or maybe a negative like oh I
didn't book that but why her not me you
know I used to feel that a lot like why
them not me
and you change that too man I'm just so
grateful I am so thankful to just be
here I'm so thankful that you're giving
me your time to let me read for you or
you're giving me your time to see me
I'm so thankful that that person got it
because they were the best person for
that role at that time I'm so thankful
and then you change everything to being
thankful
the process is so much easier like now I
don't worry if someone says yes or no
I'm just thankful for the opportunity
I don't I'm not concerned with if I read
for 100 casting directors or I read for
one
I don't worry if someone likes my films
or they hate my film because I only can
control what I can control so when I
make something and I put it out into the
world that's for the world to judge and
whether you like it or hate it it
doesn't bother me if you like it I'm so
glad because then I made the film for
you if you don't like it it doesn't
bother me you still watched it to come
out with the conclusion that that you
don't like it but that negative opinion
on it doesn't affect me at all and the
least bit so when you think about is it
easier now in Atlanta or California it's
like
California needed to happen
because it taught me
what I had to do
in Atlanta if I wanted to make it in
this industry
you talked about earlier flying into La
I don't know if it was Burbank or LAX
LAX okay LAX so you said you kind of saw
like the hustle and bustle and how
everybody's rushing around and I think
that the attitude that you talked about
not to beat yourself up but of how come
them and not me I think that permeates
that's just part of what happens here
unfortunately that's the Dark Side of
human nature we all have it in US yeah
and so
I think it just you know Energy's
infectious we feel it and this is what
happens here yeah and I you know so the
funny thing is when I came to La at 18
and I flew into LAX when I took that
first breath and stepped out of the
airport I was like I am home this is it
I loved it I was like yes like like you
could feel the energy differently now is
a
veteran coming back it's like oh man I I
love it but I can't wait to go home at
the same time
um
that thought of why them and not me is
very dangerous
and the reason why it's so dangerous
is because we as creators as human
beings as friends we have to take
responsibility for where we are in life
at any given moment it's no one's fault
it's not your mom's fault it's not your
past your past right your past and all
those pains are literally just memories
and feelings that you associate to those
memories that is it the past is done so
that means every day you wake up you
have the opportunity to create a new
version a better version of yourself you
also have that same opportunity to
create a worse version of yourself
so that thought the reason why it's so
dangerous of why them and not me is
because if you took the responsibility
to say let me get better
let me just get better let me just read
more let me just go over scripts more
let me just kind of see what a landscape
is let me write more Let me let me get a
camera and just kind of practice
auditioning let me set up this lighting
let me give this line
you're already moving those muscles to
become better where
be happy that they got it because they
were in the same room as you so that
means that it's possible for you to get
in
and when you just start doing these
little minute changes and you put in the
effort and you take responsibility for
your life for your career for who you
are as a person you can blossom into
whatever flower you want to be
was there a book that you read or some
conversation with someone that helped
you kind of look at
taking responsibility for where you're
at
NLP treatment
Tony Robbins
as far as taking responsibility
that would come from my wife
my wife has given me so many lessons and
I'm so thankful for it
um
so my wife is 10 years older than I am
and it's a fantastic dynamic because I'm
the creative and she's the one that dots
the eyes and T's right I couldn't have
done any of this without my wife but
she's the one that holds me
to realism right if I complain you know
oh why isn't this film doing this good
or why is this person you know
she was like well get better do better
right right better do more what are you
complaining about complaining it doesn't
do anything and then my rebuttal is I'm
just letting go of steam right I'm just
letting go of steam but
there's been no book
that's that I can say has changed my
life
there I'm not a heavy reader
um
I watched channels like this while I'm
making films right there's so much
information for filmmakers that if you
come across this video go to the library
of film courage and you'll find whatever
it is that you're looking for that can
help change your life this
field that we're in
if you can find someone to hold you
accountable
and to
throw those excuses right in your face
and tell you that you're making excuses
like the way my wife does to me
you'll LeapFrog who you were and I know
your wife she's kind of self-made as
well yeah so my wife is from Puerto Rico
um
and she was in the I.T field for like 20
years and that's why she knew to have me
go into I.T uh and then she started uh
I'm gonna say she even though it's it's
a Unity but in reality it's really she
runs it uh a med spa in Georgia and then
we created a reality show for The Med
Spa very cool yeah and you can see that
um so yeah so that we actually did
independent distribution through film
Hub we created uh three episodes so
three 20-minute episodes uh for the spa
and uh
it's in Roswell it's called Park Ave
cosmetic Center and we went through film
Hub and the reason why we went through
film Hub is because this is a local show
right a local space we're able to do all
of the advertisements for it locally so
it's not an international thing where
it's like hey let's try and procure a
distributor even though there's a bunch
of horror stories with distribution but
the truth is they have certain channels
that you as a filmmaker just don't have
access to so I said hey you know let's
go through film Hub because we'll have
control over it 100 and then we can do
all of the marketing locally ourself
so it's past quality control
um and then now it'll probably be up on
Amazon Prime and like to be here soon so
we're just waiting on that yep
your message to artists don't quit your
day job yes
so
it's so important because it goes back
to what we were saying about having your
your a goal and your B goal and by you
having a day job for me anyways it gave
me the stability to create my own films
right I was able to procure locations
feed casts take care of them do films do
projects because I had a day job if I
only worried about booking jobs
to live I would be struggling because I
haven't booked a job in this field in
like five six years
so then that means I would go five or
six years without any income looking to
work as a PA on set or you know having
to do background work or having to do
Oddball jobs whereas when you agree when
you get that skill
you're able to just build the foundation
and without the foundation you can't do
anything
but with the foundation of Financial
Security and it doesn't matter how much
you make
thirty thousand fifty thousand eighty
thousand you know how much you're
bringing in so you can kind of mold your
life around it
then you're able to create you're able
to know okay I'm off Friday Saturday
Sunday I'm gonna film Fridays and
Saturday nights or Saturdays and Sun
however you're going to do it and I'm
just going to do that slowly
consistency for a Creator is more
important than anything so if you're a
writer I have a goal that I live by
if I'm planning on writing a script
because I like a story
I do a minimum of three pages a day
and that minimum means if I can get
three pages a day then in a month I have
a script
if you do one page a day and you hold
yourself to that one page in three
months you'll have a script but if
you're not disciplined enough to hold
yourself to that one page or three pages
then you'll never have anything and that
story will stay stuck in your head
so when you have discipline you have
your your goal a goal B it becomes so
important because you're able to get a
lot further think about it if you go to
the gym and you're disciplined to work
out every day you're going to get
stronger
so if you're a filmmaker and you're
disciplined to shoot every weekend
discipline discipline okay maybe it took
you six months but now in six months
compared to you thinking about doing
something it's done
that Turtle verse the race uh that
turtle versus the rabbit that we all
used to listen to and how the turtle
used to win
you don't understand it as a kid when
you're younger because you're like the
rabbit is way faster
but consistency can move mountains
so be consistent
okay let me just play the opposite
approach for a minute though let's
suppose you get this great job I.T it's
very in demand especially now post
pandemic
what if you get into a lifestyle now you
have a nice car now you have a nice
place now you have friends coming over
for dinner and they're in the same
profession or or similar and and then
there's this little gnawing at you and
you're like you know what I don't want
to be at this keyboard right now I want
to be creating something I had that
and that's what led me to making films
once you
get that creative bug
kind of never leaves you because even
though I kind of quit Hollywood I didn't
stop
that feeling never left me of wanting to
create and wanting to see something
so lifestyle working in the job you
can't make the excuses
if you want to do it you have to find
time right and I say that because I'm
married I still have time for my wife
I'm a father I still have time for my
son we do his Kumon and his schoolwork
and I pick him up from the bus stop
I still work 40 hours a week at my job
when I get off at five
I can either write a script from five to
six I can edit a film from five to six
that consistency as a turtle
every day of one hour two hours of
creative output
leads to a mountain of work
in three years
from an independent standpoint
you have three films
you have a web series with 12 to 13
episodes
you have a reality show about a med spa
and then you have a reality pilot
episode
in three years
and you're only able to do that if
you're consistently pounding at it so
even if you're in a career instead of
mindlessly searching through social
media and letting an hour pass by
you can go and align that effort towards
what it is that you're trying to
accomplish so again if you're trying to
write a script or you're trying to write
a book do a page a day because in three
months your script is done
if you're shooting a film
shoot one day a week
and then before you know it if it's 16
days okay in four months you're done
shooting and now you're in post and then
you apply that same tactic go edit for
an hour
go edit on the weekend
it's all about balance and consistency
because you still need time for your
friends you still need time for your
spouse or significant other you still
need time for your kids you need time
for yourself
I do all that while I still play video
games right it's important to have that
balance but if you are a creative and I
think someone gave me this statistic I
think like 12 percent of the world are
creatives
and then 98 of filmmakers never make a
second film right those two kind of
Statistics I think are accurate but I
could be wrong if 12 of the world are
creatives then that and the whole world
consumes art right every film is Art
every commercial every story is art
then that means if you're one of those
creatives and that kind of sticks with
you and that's like the invisible Wings
on your back that that you just have to
fly
then you owe it to yourself
and you owe it to your to the world
to let that art out because if you die
one day with that art inside of you
and you're old and you're only stuck
with your thoughts
you don't want to live a life or leave a
life with regrets you want to leave a
life regardless of the success attached
to it
with I did it I tried my best and I gave
my best effort
the results are out of your hands
because even films with hundreds of
millions of dollars in budget flop
the success is out of your hands the
creation
and given it its best effort
is within your capabilities
so before you leave this earth
do everything that you can to get that
feeling that that conscious art out of
you because if you don't do it in that
web of Consciousness somebody else is
going to pull it
so
for example I wasn't planning on making
pizza boy Rick which is my latest film
that's in post I wasn't planning on
making it at all I was at a Cisco event
as an engineer
for three days in Vegas
and I was laying in bed by myself just
randomly watching TV the thought came to
me instantly the whole story I could see
play in my head
I went into my phone in my notes and I
just wrote points uh Rick goes here okay
this would this is what happens and then
I came back wrote the script in about a
week
if I didn't pull that
from the artistic Consciousness that all
creators I think pull ideas from
somebody else would have
so I think it's important
to give it your best effort
for yourself as a human being and for
your soul
because we all die
and you don't want to be on your
deathbed saying man
I wish I would have done things
differently
do you think that nine to five gives you
structure where you know you have this
hour before you have to I don't know
pick up your son or take him to Kumon or
whatever and and you're like I have to
do this now or it's not going to happen
it gives me stability because we would
all love to just make films full-time
and be like Spielberg or Christopher
Nolan or Quentin Tarantino we would all
love that we would all want to be in
that position
but until you're in that position
then you have to do
what works
and what I've realized growing up and
going through life is that life does not
have to be a struggle
when you grow up poor like I did in many
other people in the world
you think that struggle is normal that
you have to struggle
but when you realize that hey if I just
take these steps in life differently
maybe I don't have to struggle well
guess what if you're back to being that
18 year old kid that wants to fly out
because you don't have a stable home and
you want to go and you're just going to
try it and and struggle along the way
unless you get that Lottery lucky break
compared to that same 18 year old that
goes to the military which I had this
conversation with my brother hey go to
the Army four years you get the VA loan
so that means you automatically get
approved for a house you can rent out
that house rent out those rooms stay in
one of the rooms and they pay for your
mortgage you can get one percent down on
a million dollar loan for your business
uh so you can buy a business that
generates money for you and then you do
those few things outside of them paying
for your degree and going to school
while you're learning and you're a young
man now you come out in four years at 22
with a degree that's paid for no debt
the ability to get a small business loan
and buy a home that's all provided for
you because you you sacrifice four years
or you gave four years now you took your
life in your own hands and gave yourself
a leg up right because now you have
these options so now you can pursue
whatever it is you want to pursue from a
stable point of view compared to
I'm just going to go out and I'm going
to try and figure it out I'm just going
to try and figure it out like for some
people it works
but when I say life doesn't have to be a
struggle
it doesn't if you just make the right
choices
if you just and someone can say well
what's the right choices right okay so
I'll step back and say if you just make
more calculated choices
I think you can get to your destination
without as much pain
you know it's funny you say that you you
if you had an open schedule
if something
an open schedule can sometimes be
detrimental too because now you can put
stuff off because you're your own
Taskmaster so you really have to like
reevaluate once you have that open
schedule to-do list fixes all that sure
so if you have a to-do list
and and you kind of write what you want
to accomplish
you'll be surprised at how fast you can
get that to-do list done
if you stick to because every story
starts on a piece of paper or on your
screen you have to write the words down
before you make a film right
if you have a to-do list and on that
to-do list I have to do laundry I have
to do work I have to write this page for
the script I have to you know take my
son to the dentist
okay
if you just mark it off and you look at
that to-do list
you'll realize how quickly you're able
to get things done but that to-do list
holds you accountable if you're looking
at it
now with that open schedule if you don't
have a to-do list
you're fiddling around you're wasting
time for me one of my greatest assets
because I'm not the best director
there's other directors that are better
I'm not the best cinematographer there's
other cinematographers that are better
not the best writer I'm not the best
anything but what I am
are two things
I'm a grinder I will grind it Non-Stop
and knock on the door Non-Stop
and I I get laser focused
so that laser focus helps out a lot
because when I stick to okay my rule was
three pages a day I tend to write 12 to
15 a day because writers know like once
you start getting in the flow the story
kind of writes itself and kind of goes
and I don't worry about punctuation I
don't worry about spelling correctly
sometimes I don't even worry about
describing a scene I'll say interior uh
house in Alaska
fireplace
Jim walks into the front door the fire
is burning
there is no
the smell of the burning wood
permeates through the building you can
see the smoke as it leaves the front
door Jim walks in the door creaks for
what when I shoot it it's going to
either Creek or it's not going to Creak
when I edit it and I do sound design
it's either I'm going to add it or I'm
not so if you're going to sell it you
need to colorize it but if you're going
to film it then don't get caught up on
making those words sound perfect get
caught up on how to make the story that
you see in your head out on that paper
and then how can you the best to your
abilities get that shot
who are your favorite Asian actors
Okay so
I love Jackie Chan
and I love what he's done and I love how
he brought comedy
or I would say comedic gestures with
almost all of his films
um
and on the opposite end I would say Jet
Li because in my time in the 90s growing
up and stuff you had Jackie Chan and you
had Jet Lee Jackie Chan was the colorful
fun one Jet Li was the serious one and I
know there are martial arts a lot of
times incorporated into their films but
those two were the ones that I remember
growing up watching all the time
so if we gave you let's say 50 right now
can you name 50 Asian American actors
absolutely not from the 1960s 70s 80s
and 90s 50 from all those decades
combined uh no I can't what motivates
you to make movies more than anything
else
so it's a few things I really want to
influence a generation
of American Asians I want to
even if it's to crack that barrier
I want to move that barrier as much as I
can and what I mean by that is like
I want to see Asian Americans in
American Cinema playing every role
I don't want to see us stuck to be in
the sidekick
the the nerdy friend
the Kung Fu karate guy
I want us to play every role like
and Top Gun
what did the Top Gun pilot the lead guy
was an Asian guy
it's about a pilot right or you know
um
even something like Batman Batman you
could get away with an Asian American
just because it's the dark hair
the build you can kind of get away with
that
um
I really want to help even Fast and
Furious one of my favorite movies of all
time
you know if Vin Diesel's character or
Paul Walker's character was an
Asian-American guy
be fantastic because now you're just
seeing that right uh
it changes a landscape of what someone
sees as possible when they're able to
see it happen consistently not the
one-offs because you're always going to
have the one-offs
but when you're able to see big
blockbusters
with an Asian American in the leading
role the main guy or main female
I think it changes the Dynamics for a
whole generation because now
somebody else can see that and say well
I can do that too so now you have a
plethora of films you have a bunch of
different creators and writers and the
filmmakers directors coming out with
these projects because they've seen it
it's like
um I don't remember the exact name but
there was a long time where the four
minute mile
uh that it took for someone to run a
four minute mile and then once he did it
I think it was like weeks or months or
19 days I forget the exact number for
someone else to break that four minute
mile
but he had to have broken it first
in order for someone else to see that
it's possible and then everyone else
broke the four minute mile
so it's the same thing with film
you have to see
Someone Like You break that mold
for you to say
okay I can do that too
yeah absolutely I can do that too
so you know it's similar to
Keanu Reeves right Keanu Reeves is a
great example of someone that broke that
mold
but how many Keanu Reeves are there
not that many so I'm hoping to to help
break that door whether it's the front
door side door we built a new house in
that neighborhood
and and present the to the world that
hey we're more than just the punch line
Dean Kane yes and Dean Kane Dean Kane
played Superman sure
great example
so I I think that if we're able to do
more of that
we're able to to impact Cinema in a
large way and if you think about it from
a business standpoint
there's so many Asians in the world
why wouldn't you want to tap into that
market
full blast
when you were going on auditions in La
um what did casting directors tell you
was your look and did you ever turn down
roles because you thought I don't want
to play a stereotype so I turned down a
lot of roles in Atlanta
or a lot of I'm not going to say roles
because they weren't presented but
auditions where I didn't even audition
for them and it could have probably hurt
me where the castner at some point was
like all right we don't even want to see
him because he turns everything down but
in LA
I was so hungry for any role
that I would have taken any role
but it was always the same rules we're
the same actors who are always in the
room in hindsight
it was great because you know you're
getting an opportunity because again no
one's going to create that role for you
unless you created yourself because
you're not proven right I'm not proven
um
unless something does well that I'm in
in this particular role because now
there's data associated with that where
it's like okay well people like seeing
this guy play this role
there's no data behind it then there's
no gauge and if there's no gauge there's
no money that you can associate it with
it because every time you spend a dollar
they want to get two or three back
so
the machine itself did
what worked for for hundreds of years
but in order to innovate we have to
innovate we have to create and become
the creators
so you would take any role in La what
did the casting directors tell you was
your look do you know
so here's where I had a double-edged
sword
when they looked at my picture they're
like okay great bring them in when I
opened my mouth
they were like he's not the guy
so it worked in commercials in print
but I was never Asian enough
so because I was never Asian enough
when I opened my mouth
they said I sound too Urban
those are the exact words you sound too
Urban You're not Asian enough
it's
it's interesting
because
I know when they say you're not Asian
enough I know what that means
I know what they're looking for
and they're right I'm not that and
in hindsight
I just want to
show that everyone is everyone
sure we all have common pains we all
have common Joys you know emotions are
Universal
so words can be interpreted differently
depending on the language and where
you're from
but a happy emotion regardless of where
you're from is the same
a sad emotion is the same
so the one thing that's beautiful about
films is you're able to evoke those
emotions and a lot of times those
emotions span Beyond where you're from
that when you came to Atlanta and you
were more established with your day job
and and well rooted you turned down
roles was it the same thing you felt
like okay now I don't want to contribute
to the stereotype being out there
absolutely 100 so when I I want to say
gain the power of creating films so when
I did my first film it was my film
school right I learned everything from
YouTube film courage I decided that okay
I'm gonna shoot this film right I was
working I.T I started writing the film
during my break so when I wasn't doing
anything started shooting it on the
weekends casting it all that stuff
is it a great film absolutely not you're
either gonna love it or hate it but it
taught me so much where the what you see
on screen from first film the second
film
has such a drastic jump up in quality
and Style and what I'm trying to
accomplish that that first film needed
to happen in order for me to LeapFrog
because that did two things it let me
know what I needed to get better at and
then it let me know that I can do it
again because you did it
so that's why it's so important for
filmmakers to get that first one don't
wait for the right opportunity don't
wait for the right time don't wait for
the right circumstances we all want to
shoot 100 000 cameras and lenses and and
have you know 10 hours to shoot one
scene but when you're an indie filmmaker
you're gonna shoot 10 scenes in three
hours
you're not going to get that many takes
because you only have this location for
four
and you have to set up pack up shoot get
out clean it up make sure you leave it
better than where you when you got in
so
that stability
was was crucial
and allowing me to create
how do you write a screenplay in a week
so I stick to the three pages a day Rule
and then if the story just starts
flowing then it'll start flowing on its
own and I kind of let that take its
place and then when I start feeling
fatigued I stop because when you're
fatigued you're not gonna do yourself
Justice
so if you think about a week 90 pages
15 20 Pages you can knock that out if
you're in a flow
you have to just keep doing it every day
just do it when you find those Pockets
what I would do is I'd work work work
when I'd have a breathing room because
no one's working eight hours straight
non-stop unless you're like doing road
work or something for the most part you
have your little break Bubbles and what
I would do during my break bubbles is I
would shift and I would write so I'd
write like a page or two and then I'd go
back to work and then I'd write another
page or two and go back to work so I
would be consistently outputting because
the story like as I'm working on this
thing and I'm doing this the story's in
my head so when I'm working on it I'm
thinking about a story like okay this
character can go here okay boom then
I'll go here and I write so it's just
about utilizing those pockets of free
time to write and it again if you stick
to the three pages a day 30 days you
have a full feature film but if you did
six now you got it in 15 if you did nine
you have it in pretty much about seven
days
and you said that the stories once you
get started pretty much writes itself
have you ever had it where the story is
not writing itself and you know okay
this isn't going anywhere no
um because I'm not concerned with making
it like someone else's story
I'm not concerned with and now we're all
going to pull from what we're influenced
by our favorite movies like you're gonna
you're gonna have similar stories but
when I write
I like the bad guy winning sometimes I
like you know
things happening that you just don't see
coming
so when I write there's the only
structure really there's only one thing
that I follow as my guide in my draw I'm
not a master writer there's this this is
not a master class but the one thing I
follow is what's making these characters
move forward
what's making these characters move
forward and what I noticed is a lot of
my films they all take place within two
days
so as an indie filmmaker it's a lot
easier to shoot two days because people
don't really have to change outfits like
people can wear the same thing in two
days so you're able to save that
um
and you're able to tell a blip of a
story within that two days so if you
have to do a period piece or something
that takes over a year or two years or
you don't know how many days then
there's a lot of things that you add as
far as complexity so I kind of steer
away from that and I do like stories
that are within a small space and the
reason why I don't get hung up on
something is because I kind of just let
it go and whatever happens is whatever
happens
um
if it's received well it's received well
if it's not it's not but what you do
know when you watch it is huh
that's a unique take on it that's
interesting that's not what I would like
let's say if you're a writer watching it
that's not what I would I was taught to
write because there should be more back
and forth conflict like if I watch a
movie and you're able to take somebody
out
it drives me crazy when like let's say
you beat up the bat like Michael Myers
you beat him up and you get in the car
and then you drive off like run them
over 10 times like run them over and
then like make sure he's good and then
drive off uh in my stories it's very
like kind of like linear it's like okay
we're gonna get from point A to point D
and we're gonna go here and what is
what's allowing these characters to go
here and that's just the process that I
use
and for me it's it's been working
because I've been able to get out
stories now whether they're the best or
they're not the only thing that I ever
try to do and this is from an acting
standpoint uh writing standpoint
filmmaking is I just try to make things
that are entertaining I don't care about
winning Awards I don't care about being
the best actor can I get you entertained
can I get you to laugh once can I get
you to be like oh that was cool oh I
like that oh no get that again if I can
get you to do that once within that film
I did my job outside of that
I I don't chase Perfection because I
don't think Perfection is real you can
have masterpieces absolutely but there's
Beauty
in the imperfections so
I think it's more important to get out
that vision
than to wait for everything to be
perfect or for you to create Perfection
because what happens
if you're able to create Perfection for
90 but you're not able to finish
a hundred percent and you have something
that's been sitting there for 10 15
years and now you've gotten into a point
in your life where you're in this rhythm
you're in this routine and you weren't
able to finish your perfection
I think it's better to get it out and
get it done and get better and get
better and and get master your craft and
get better and kind of learn from the
mistakes that you make evolve enhance
influence Inspire other people
and with that you're able to create more
and I think it's more important to have
20 shots
at this dream that we're all pursuing
than to have one shot
and I like my odds better at 20 shots
how do you organize scenes and structure
a screenplay Okay so
90 pages
I don't really go by arcs
so if you go back to okay what's driving
them forward you have this this mission
right whatever it is that drives them
forward
as an indep me writing it as an indie
filmmaker I know that I can't go super
crazy
because I have to be able to capture it
so I can't do cars exploding drifting
off of a bridge into a helicopter like I
can't do that not to say that I can't
but I'm limited at that moment in time
and space to accomplish that so
when I write I write what's feasible
I write 90 pages I don't write 120 130
and I have to chop away it's 90 page I
write what I know I can film and what
I'm going to film
um and then I write locations that I I'm
pretty confident that I can procure and
then once that's done I break the scenes
down by location
so if I have 15 locations in the film
then each location is associated with a
scene number so then now when I go to
that location I know we're doing scene 7
29 and 3. and then the actors all know
okay we're doing 7 29 and 3 because
that's what's associated with this
location so when you break down scenes
and scripts this way by locations and
the scenes associated with those uh
locations
and you take away the magic Allure of it
and you just put in the work because in
reality all we're doing is lighting
audio and we're pushing record that's it
you take away the thought of I need 20
crew members I need a PA I need a I need
this I need that take all that away
and just think about what is the work
the work is to capture your story in
front of the lens to the best of your
ability at that time
so once you're able to do that and
you're able to break it down into these
sections now you know okay I have 15
locations I have 15 shoot days so let's
plan around these 15 shoe days we have
three scenes six scenes two scenes I
have four hours two hours three hours
now you created a plan
on how to shoot your film
now those are just consistent small
steps that you do non-stop then when you
get to that last location and you shoot
those scenes you're now done and you're
working on the pulse production on
editing color grading sound design
voices and you're doing all of that but
as far as shooting because you created a
plan on how you were going to do it
and you were consistent about it
you did it
and that's kind of how I break down
films I break down films by scenes and
locations and I tie them together so
then when I get a location if I have to
do 10 scenes
in three hours I know we have to fly
there's no there's no Double Take triple
take we gotta fly but if I have one
scene for one location I can get 100
shots and take my time with it so you'll
have some scenes that turn out better
than others because you had more time
with it
but it's better to have a completed film
and continue to get better
than to just try and get that perfect
shot and then now instead of a 16 15
shoot day you have a 50 60 shoe day that
took three or four years
because you didn't plan
how did you create the character of Ace
in four Leos
so Ace four Amigos
pose a lot of influence from Fast and
the Furious
um I think any film with cars pulls from
Fast and Furious but Ace is is almost
like
Paul Walker's character but Asian
um
I just wrote what I wanted to see on
screen and I pulled from the things that
I love
one of the main things that I've loved
since I was a teenager is cars in the
car culture in the car community
and they are so abrasive of each other
right it doesn't matter if you have a
fifteen hundred dollar Honda Civic that
you built up in your garage or you have
uh eighty thousand dollars CA Corvette
it just doesn't matter like there's love
for cars which turns into love for
people
so with Ace's character I knew okay what
could I do to move the story forward
what can I shoot
that's
feasible
from where I am currently at in life
I said okay his mom is sick and he has
to rob somebody
how can I incorporate cars
without making it you know have cheesy
card dialogue and stuff
and my dialogue is very simple because
it's really my my films are more
I think story driven
and the characters are kind of just
develop compared to character driven and
then the story develops so I'm more
interested in the story
of how did they get from point A to
point d right how did it get there and
with Ace I was like okay how can I
how can I make him
get to where he's trying to get to and
incorporate cars that was the main thing
because I had access to these cars these
amazing cars and I knew that I had a
higher level of success with the niche
film right so like
if I was going to make a film about cars
I know there's an audience a
multi-billion dollar audience attached
to that
and I I own all the Fast and the Furious
Blu-rays I watch like all of them yearly
I'll go and just do a Marathon run
because I just love cars and I love car
films and car culture so by me uh Not Me
By Us creating a tuner film
we automatically had that Niche audience
because I know they're going to want to
see the NSX The Supercharged BRZ these
cars I know they're going to want to see
it so by having that Niche audience we
have a greater level and greater chance
of success
so then it was just about incorporating
my character into that space how can I
get him into a
action-esque film how can I give them
the biggest chance to succeed and when I
write these scripts and I write these
stories I write myself in mind for parts
that I want to see someone like myself
play
um
so by having that connection to his mom
anybody can relate because anybody would
do anything to help save their mom or
their dad so that already connects to
the human portion of of who we are then
to go rob the bad guy I painted the bad
guys a real bad guy so when things
happen throughout the story or when
things happen at the end you were like
yeah he was so nasty I'm so glad they
got him and then for the good guys to
win even though I do like the bad guys
winning in this particular story it was
about the good guys winning and then
setting up the sequel
um
there's a lot of scenes where cars are
in the film way longer than a normal
film would have had them because I knew
car guys just want to see those shots so
I left them in there but it was really
about just kind of like a hero's journey
um about a guy that is into car culture
that saves his mom
how did you raise the budget for Rex
Park Curse of the Golden Buddha so we we
took that out of our savings and you
know for that
we've been saving for years and I just
had this conversation with my wife uh
really for all of our films it's like I
have to make this I just I don't know
what it is about me but I have to make
this and
I needed to get it out of my system and
I thought that
when I made Rex Park I thought that if I
make this I'm good because I made it I
gave myself a shot
but that wasn't the case
but it was the case when I made four
Amigos
when I made four Migos
I was okay with never making another
film again or not even being a part of
the industry again because that was what
I needed for my internal soul to
accomplish
um and then obviously it led to other
stuff but
I think sometimes you have a voice in
you
and you can choose to listen to it and
apply action
or you can ignore it
and
I don't think I could have I would have
regretted life
if
I didn't listen to that voice that said
you've got to do it you can't you can't
give up now
um you have to do it
so I dipped into my savings
and mind you when we talk about
stability being in I.T it gave me the
ability to have a savings and and my
wife work in us working together and
aligning our efforts and savings to make
those films
it was so vital towards the maturity
of myself as a creator
because even though
some people would say it's horrible some
people will love it it's low level sex
fart jokes
it's very experimental like when
different characters come up on the
barcodes it'll be yellow for one
character and then purple for another
character or when my character gets
slapped with poop the barcodes turn
brown like it was and there's cheesy
really just bad Graphics it was very
experimental that I found hilarious
because that's just my sense of humor
um my wife absolutely hates it I have
friends that absolutely hate it and then
I have other people that absolutely love
it and I knew that that's what that film
was when I created it but by creating
that film
in getting the confidence in this in the
schooling of doing there's something to
be said about experience and doing
that
once you're able to build that
confidence and that trust in yourself
that you can do it and you're able to
see like onset
where you can get better how you can get
better how you can treat people better
how you can talk to people better how
you can collaborate better because you
can't make a film without all of your
talent and crew you just can't it you
can shoot yourself but it's a boring
film you need the collaborate
collaborative effort of everyone
um and that's the beauty of film it's
it's collaboration
but without it I would have never gotten
to the point where I'm at now which is
10 steps further than where I was three
years ago because the films the national
commercials the print jobs and I've
worked with Apple Samsung McDonald's
Subway like you name it I didn't do
anything for my career they didn't push
me forward or anything it all it did was
give me knowledge
um as to what it looks like on set how
do people kind of do things I did take
that experience and then applied it to
my films
um but it
you have to get that first film Out The
Way
what resources did you already have
so I had the Blackmagic pocket Cinema
Camera 6K
so here's one of the big lessons that I
learned on Rex Park to four Amigos in a
pizza boy rig on Rex Park I had the
Sigma 18 to 35 millimeter lens because
everyone raved oh this is the land the
sharpness it's so great
they're right it's a good lens but what
I realized in making that first film is
what my style was and what I wanted to
capture you can't capture within 18 to
35 mil
I like shooting in 50 mil to 100 Mil and
in that space
so because I I realized that that with
the Blackmagic camera now with the
Blackmagic pocket Cinema Camera six to
6K you shoot that Raw
and I paired that with the Canon L2
series lens 24 to 105 lens
it's did two things it gave me the focal
range that I wanted
and it allowed me to save time on set
because a lot of times you're running
and gunning when you're shooting because
I didn't have to change out the lens I
could just zoom in zoom out zoom in zoom
out
it it changed everything for me because
I was able to get a higher quality
production just out of the the lens
camera setup because in reality yeah you
can have the three-point lighting system
right front side and the back to kind of
separate you from the background but
when you're shooting 10 scenes in three
hours in one location you don't have
time for all that so make sure that that
person that's in light that okay they're
good and you can be agile so every time
you shoot a new scene you're going to
move that light boom but if you have to
set up three lights
you might not be able to get that in
time and if you don't do it that day you
might not be able to get that location
again
so there's there's little things and
caveats that you learn
from shooting a movie and having that
black magic with that 24 to 105 mil lens
and one powerful lighting just one I
would tell any filmmaker we all know
lighting is is one of the most important
things when shooting
spend the money on a real powerful light
because that one powerful light would do
you more Justice than having three
lights that aren't as powerful and I
learned that on my lesson on Rex park
because we were shooting this scene on
the background right and it was really
bright it was sunny outside and one of
the things that I hate and I did it and
I hate it when I see it but it was it's
because the tools that I had at the time
is for any filmmaker out there if you
want to light it right you light for the
background
you put that
um
uh you put your aperture settings for
the background so it's not overblown and
you can see all the details then you
light artificially your actor in frame
so then that's how you get that really
good dynamic range and balance where the
background is not overblown and this
person is is in shot lit well if you
like the actor in front and it's so
bright in the back then that means
that's going to be blown out just so you
can like this person well and that tends
to not look well in the final product
so lens
camera
one powerful light and sometimes you can
even just do like a little bounce board
to just kind of get what's bouncing off
so you already had those in your
filmmaking kit
if it will I bought those oh you bought
those yeah so I bought the black magic
pocket Cinema Camera 6K because I knew
that it was probably the most cinematic
looking camera that you could get at the
time for that budget
um and then I bought the sigma and then
and then I bought cheap lights that's
how I knew like the eBay light kit even
though there's three of them it just it
did what it needed to do to teach me my
lesson but it wasn't good enough to
produce the result that I wanted from a
production value and quality standpoint
but I did have to bite down and buy the
camera and buy the lens
ah but then you use them going forward
to other Productions okay so that helps
with the budget going absolutely because
now it's almost like an investment
you already own that and there's there's
power especially in 2022 there's power
in owning your gear because you don't
have to wait to shoot something you can
shoot it outside in your yard your Park
your parking garage your friend's house
you can shoot because you own it so when
you buy gear in a sense you're investing
in yourself and the extension of your
capabilities
do you ever factor in when will this
gear be obsolete when will I when will I
need to move on there'll be something
bigger and better
no because you know you can still watch
a DVD that shot and forward that that is
in 480p final rendered and still enjoy
it and in reality this is a really good
advice for filmmakers
you have to make sure that if you're
shooting in 6K 4K 12K that your computer
can handle it because if you don't have
the right GPU CPU RAM and all of that
stuff to shoot
it's it's not going to work so like with
editing four Amigos and Pizza Boy Rick I
had to buy a 3090 TI I didn't want to
put that on my credit card but I had to
buy that GPU to edit because once you
add color grading and a lot of times I
like to sonically and Visually I like my
films to kind of look like 80s and 90s
really I like it to look 90s but
sonically sound 80s
um
that once you
convert that digital footage to film
grain you add your color grade you
soften the images so it doesn't have
that digital sharp look because it's
film
that GPU and that CPU is working and
your computer will have a hard time even
with the 3090 TI to do 6K raw a lot of
times you have to take that 6K do a
1080p timeline do all your editing and
hope that when you render in something
like DaVinci that it doesn't crash
so making sure that your computer is is
Beefy enough to handle that footage is a
big thing because if not
don't let that stop you from not filming
but maybe the black magic six is not the
best option maybe the Blackmagic 4K
is the best option because you can shoot
4K raw and maybe that doesn't tax your
system as much or maybe the original
black magic where you still get that
cinematic 1080p because your system can
handle that 1080p
but it's better for you to to be
Progressive and shoot and make
advancements
than to wait and wait and wait for gear
now if you're going to upgrade from
something like the original black magic
or you can get something better
then yeah save up for it plan for it but
don't let that stop you from creating
what does DCA mean Ah that's a good one
so DCA is what I live by decide what
you're going to do
how you're going to do it
commit to that decision
and then apply action
if you can do those three things you
will always succeed and that's always
kind of been my Mantra right so if you
think about
making a movie filmmaking
I decide I'm going to make this movie
okay how are you going to make this
movie I'm going to write this script and
I'm going to break it down into steps
and create a plan
okay great commit you have to now commit
to that plan commit to those steps that
you created and commit to making that
movie
action now I'm moving my body and I'm
I'm moving my fingers I'm making phone
calls I'm sending emails and I'm gonna
do that to be successful so just by
doing those three things and holding
yourself accountable to those three
things you can create a film I always
say like if you can answer this one
question you can make a movie can you
finish it
if you can look in the mirror and say
yes I can finish it then you can make a
movie because if you've already
committed to yourself that you can
finish it then you just gotta start
and a lot of people that
collaborate with me and they know if I
decide like Hey we're gonna do this it's
as good as done it's it's as good as
done because I don't make that decision
that I'm gonna do something unless I'm
gonna finish it so if I'm on the fence
about something
ah we don't really know what's gonna
happen with that but if I'm like all
right it's go time we're gonna do it
it's as good as done
which of the three do you do you
struggle with or have you struggled with
in the past the D the C A the D
I think
the decision is the hardest
because once you decide
you're allotting your life energy to
that and I think in life we're like a
battery we have so much energy before it
goes to zero
so when you decide that you're going to
do something like when I decided I was
going to do four Migos
I knew it was a massive undertaking
I knew it was dangerous I knew that uh
it was a lot of sweat I knew that it
would take a lot of effort
so I had to decide that I was going to
do it
the once you get past D you've already
gotten to the gate of the house so the
committing in action that's the easy
part because you've already made that
decision
so it's the decision part
have you always been this disciplined
yes
uh
I always kept my room clean
um
in order to make movies in order to make
money growing up in Hawaii we sold food
so my stepmom
uh she didn't have a degree
she
on paper wasn't the smartest but what
she had in abundance was love
and Common Sense
that Common Sense I've carried with me
my entire life
and um
when I would not go to school or say oh
I don't feel good
she would make me make food so we would
make pasteles and Loud house and got
Duty rice and we would drive from Hilo
to Kona and we would go to all the
construction sites and we would come out
and we would sell food right and I would
have to go knock and go see these people
early on
and that's where the nose and the nah or
the yes you know we would have to before
we could leave we'd have to sell out the
coolers of food that we made
and that taught me a valuable lesson
that if you don't want to do this for
the rest of your life then you better
get disciplined because you're able to
go a lot further in life on being
disciplined than you are on just being a
wild man
because behind any successful wild man
he has to be somewhat disciplined
because how else did he become
successful and we're not talking about
trust fund or anything you're talking
about like okay he became successful and
now he's wild he's living his best life
let's say
he still had to show up he still had to
create he still had to sell he's still
had to hire the right people so he still
had to be disciplined uh to do whatever
it is that they accomplished
did you like Pursuit of Happiness
I did
but I would never make a pursuit of
happiness so
80s 90s to me were the were the best ERA
of film right and the reason why I say
that is because we had just enough
technology
to enjoy everything but we had enough
time to really enjoy it to talk with
your neighbors hey have you seen this
episode of this or have you seen did you
go to the store and rent this movie so
you could sit on a film it was like a
gift that you had that you can consume
right
and
those films and those errors in that
time frame
I feel like they didn't really have as
much of a sensor and I I want to say
almost like a responsibility or like a a
filter
that there is today so with Pursuit of
Happiness I
it was a great performance from Will
Smith it was a beautifully shot and
executed film
but
for me I like films that take me away
from the daily life I don't want to see
struggle I don't want to see you know
someone broke and they made it out like
I don't want to see that necessarily I I
like
obviously as creators you create what
you can create so you create the stories
that you're able to create in the in the
space that you're written but if I had
50 million dollars or 100 million
dollars I wouldn't create
you know a story like a Rex park or even
a pizza boy Rick for that matter I would
create Aliens versus Predators you know
um Avatar I like things that expand the
imagination I like things that take you
away from life for a second and teleport
you into a new world I like things that
that that take like humans and really
just multiply them into like this this
different atmosphere so if you think of
Avatar and you think what he James
Cameron was able to create with Avatar I
remember watching it coming out of the
theater like man life seems so boring
because Avatar had these vibrant colors
in this different world that it really
transported you to if you think of you
know something like um
The Matrix Terminator 2 Judgment Day
like these things are so even though
they have human stories right
they're so futuristic and sci-fi and so
out there even like apocalyptic films
that it makes me go like oh wow that's
cool like oh I love that
Star Wars you know anything that that
really
takes the imagination to the edge of its
seat is where I would love to be
because I feel like
as humans we all live
struggle we all live
happiness and pain I don't for me I
don't
enjoy watching
a pure just human story as much
because I want to escape when I watch a
film like if you watch Top Gun man
you're a fighter pilot you're you're
you're in that chat you know how to fly
planes you hear the sounds and and and
you see what they see from the cockpit
it's like yes I want to experience that
I don't want to experience uh we're
struggling we're eating ramen noodles
and then you know my mom hustled and
made it out and then gave us a better
life
because I lived a lot of that so I don't
I don't need to see it
but
if I'm able to witness oh the
Terminators coming from the future to
take this kid out who's the future
leader and then there's these robots in
this this monster truck is going off of
The Cliff it's like oh wow that is
incredible like I just saw ambulance on
the plane here and that is action pack
from like after the first 10 minutes to
the end of the film where I watch it
like oh my goodness like do you know how
much effort it takes to make a film
that has this much action Non-Stop
for like an hour and a half straight
right I think that you have a greater
appreciation for films
as a creative that's done it
then someone that's only ever watched
from the sidelines because you realize
no matter what level of film it is
it took so much effort
for that film to get made whether the
execution was phenomenal or the
execution
was entry level
it took so many hours
heartache
pain Joy moments to create that project
and I think that once you create
that feeling that a lot of I believe
creators have of
why him and not me
I think that goes away a lot of it
because you understand how much effort
the negativity surrounding films
it goes you're like man it's like a
thousand people like to me it blows my
mind that somebody will pay millions of
dollars for something that one person
Drew on a painting that maybe took him a
hundred hours or took her 100 hours
but a movie that took thousands of hours
hundreds of millions of dollars
they won't spend 20 bucks on Blu-ray
and it's
it it almost blows my mind
because
if you think of
subscription-based films like a Netflix
or tube or anything like that
or I know 2b's Avon but if you think of
what we have access to when it comes to
films nowadays
there's so much
and it's become so diluted
that the value of films
are not appreciated even though every
single one of us consumes films on a
daily basis
they're not appreciated in the way that
they should be
because could you imagine it tomorrow
all of a sudden films disappeared
I it would be a lackluster
color would would become a little more
dull
but that's because we have so much
access to it in as filmmakers let's say
we put a million dollars into a film
we want people to watch it so bad
to just like because every film you give
like a piece of your soul in it and you
want everybody to watch it so bad that
you're willing to let Netflix scoop it
up for 300 000 and take a seven hundred
thousand dollar loss because you know a
hundred million people can watch it and
hopefully because they watch it that
leads you to your next project
you're willing to take that Gamble
but in reality it's like your film is
worth more than that
it's
it's worth the world in gold
and I think we've lost that as people
we've lost the value of film
I want to see your story though I mean
maybe you said that you don't want to
talk about when you were telling me the
story because this is the first time I'm
hearing that I didn't see that in in the
research that we did I wanted to know
more but again that's that's your life
that's your story but
to me I wanted to follow that little boy
or however old you were
going to these construction sites I mean
that's you know maybe when I get older
my mindset would change uh I know my
mindset now at 34 is different than it
was when I was 24. very different
um but I think
that
a lot of people probably uh live that
story right we all we all struggle in a
way we all have our highs and lows
but I think if I have so many shots to
take when it comes to films because even
if you're at the highest level in a
lifetime
like a Christopher Nolan you only have
so many films in a lifetime that you're
able to make
so if I have those shots I'd rather make
the Inception
I'd rather make you know the Jurassic
Park I'd rather make those things that
really take with a kid watches in they
see Jurassic Park they're they're
enamored and just wowed by the story The
visuals and what they see so then that
expands their imagination
so if I have so many shots
I'd rather do those and fail than to
succeed and make just a grounded story
that we've already seen
how many times have you watched the
original Fast and Furious
I've watched it at least 100 times
um
I love the franchise right so it's one
of my top three favorite movies Fast and
Furious Terminator 2 and Lion King those
are my three favorite movies
um
I love everything about car culture it's
one of those things where everyone
that's kind of late 20s 30s 40s we all
watched Fast and the Furious We all
loved it at its time and it inspired a
whole generation of car lovers so
Fast and Furious is a remake kind of of
Point Break uh Point Break from with
Keanu Reeves and stuff and it follows
the same kind of story except it's
centered around street racing
and those cars today the eclipse Supra
RX7 those are so iconic in today's world
and I don't think they realized when
they created the film that it would turn
into a billion dollar 10 movie franchise
but
Fast and Furious for any car lover is
probably one of the greatest
franchises for car lovers ever to exist
because you have muscle cars you have
JDM Cars you have Euro Cars you have
exotic cars you have everything and you
know Fast and Furious one is a
masterpiece faster Too Fast Too Furious
is so enjoyable Tokyo Drift has some of
the best car sequences and it was shot
you know and the whole theme takes place
in in Tokyo and then you have four five
six seven eight nine
that slowly morphs into uh I guess like
the hero Espionage spy but still have
some cars in there
um that's what led me to make four
Amigos was after about fast and furious
five
they kind of started steering towards
towards International spies and kind of
left the tuna cars alone
and I was like okay well there's a niche
and there's a space
that is neglected and alienated and I
feel like I can help fill that void so
hopefully by this film being successful
because I already wrote the sequel It's
a three film series the sequel is done
and then I know where the third film is
going that it leads to a sequel but it
also leads to other filmmakers to make
more tuner Centric films because if I'm
able to do that and say okay hey guys we
don't all have to go to space or we
don't have to all have you know these
Oddities world events take place within
the tuner car space we can create
grounded tuner car movies
um then if I can do it you can do it too
and I would love to watch your film as
well because we all have this common
love of cars so if I open that door and
people start busting through the the
front of the house and all of a sudden
next year there's five tuner movies I
would absolutely be thrilled and
delighted because now you have more
films that interest you as a tuner lover
right it's the same as Like Loving
rom-coms or action films or sci-fi space
films the more the merrier it's the same
thing when you think about movies and
remakes and sequels and prequels like I
love it because it doesn't take away
from whatever that original was that was
your Masterpiece it's just an expansion
on that story
what is tuner culture
tuner culture is a beautiful culture
it's a culture of males females
different races ethnicities it doesn't
matter they all come together for the
love of their cars and it doesn't matter
if it's JDM
usdm or udm Euro exotic Honda Civics uh
by you expressing yourself through your
car your car almost becomes an avatar
of who you are it becomes almost like a
robot right it's an extension of you and
your soul that's why there's so much
color there's so much depth there's so
many different styles of builds you have
all motor builds stance builds body kits
track builds you have daily cars like I
personally drive a gr86 which is a
Toyota gr86
is the second generation of a BRZ GT86
and
I bought that because it's lightweight
rear-wheel drive and it has adequate
power
but tuner culture
they like to Tinker with everything
sometimes you'll have anime decals
you'll have suspension with wheels
you'll have ah let me throw on a turbo
kit or let me throw on a supercharger
kit let me add a chameleon wrap with
some 20 inch wheels with low profile
tires let me do the interior so there's
so many different ways that tuner
culture
Embraces cars
that
there's a high love there for everyone
that's why places like cars and coffee
caffeine and octane car meets on Tuesday
nights
it's such a big thing because you're
Gathering right it's something like the
what the internet brought for people
there's people that are like you that
have the same interests as you and if
you think of your childhood and I know
for my childhood my best friends we had
one thing in common and that was cars
my best friend had an MX6 with a klze
swap that I later bought from him I had
an MX3 at a time and then at the time
and then I bought a CRX my other friend
had a Subaru WRX with a STI
swap my other friend had like a Ford
Escort
but we all loved cars so after school
we'd go meet up with the cars and just
have fun right
cars
are popular and have such a large
following and fan base
because they're introduced to you as
your freedom vehicle when you first get
your license at 16.
and then they're an extension of Who You
Are
when it comes to expression
you're able to show what you have inside
on your vehicle and be like yeah this is
what I drive this is my whip
so that's why it's so important
what makes the Fast and Furious
franchise so successful
so we've grown with these characters
we've grown with these characters for
now 20 years
from the first fast and the furious to
Fast and Furious now 10. you know
all of us still feel
like the passing of Paul Walker like to
this day like we all know like there was
his memorial just took place
um
we've grown with Vin Diesel
Tyrese ludicrous like we've grown with
these characters
and
you have two audiences now yeah the tuna
culture that will always support fast
and furious because there's not many
other options out there for car films
like if you think of rom-coms or
anything else there's plenty of films
but for some reason with 200 films there
just aren't many no one else wants to
tackle it for some odd reason
um and then they have action
so now you took the formula of back in
the day where action films with Arnold
Schwarzenegger and and um uh Jean-Claude
Van Damme and you know Predator you take
that and then now you add tuner cars and
you combine them
you have a successful recipe and I think
the last five films did like a billion
at the box office or something like that
you're gonna win because even if
someone's not into tuner cards they're
into the action but then the tuner car
which is a multi-billion dollar industry
they want to see the cars too if only
now with the later films only if it's
for a little bit you still want to see
the NSX or the the Supra on a big IMAX
screen or in 4k done at the highest
level
how does the Fast and Furious rank
in all-time franchises do you know
so I don't know as far as hard numbers
but I know that for me
it's up there with
maybe even surpassed it
Terminator
um
it's up there with Star Wars it's
definitely out there with Star Wars I
can't really say Marvel because Marvel
has like 50 films with characters that
have spanded 50 to 100 years that have a
really deep following that rooted from
comic books and I don't think anything
compares to Marvel right now as far as
franchises but I would put it up there
even though James Bond has a longer list
of films I would put it up there with
with really any franchise and
what I base
films
off of and I know this this might be
different for a lot of people
are two things
enjoyability and can you re-watch it
if you have a masterpiece that you watch
sonically it's amazing visually it's
stunning editing everything about it the
film is absolutely brilliant
but when you get done watching it and
you've got the climax of it you got the
story and you never watch it again
that that kind of
sucks but that kind of sucks that now
because you've seen the Crux of it
you're like okay I don't know I don't
really need to watch it again I've seen
it right
for me something like a Fast and the
Furious
Marvel films
Star Wars alien Terminator
you can re-watch those films
and enjoy them it's like Christmas films
during Christmas you can re-watch them
and enjoy them and I'd rather have a
re-watchable film that brings enjoyment
whether you watch it yearly or during
specific events
yeah because now that film's living with
you it's growing with you you're taking
it along with you so fast and furious
definitely has that because even if
you're only into the cars
you're able to re-watch it over and over
and over if you love cars
um and I think that's a rewatchability
and enjoyment are two major things that
I think people Overlook when they judge
movies
if you judge a movie based on
and you take those things out and let's
say you have something that wins
Sundance right it's like oh it wants
Sundance It's A Beautiful film
but let's say it doesn't do well
financially and not to say everything
has to do well financially but in a
business it has to do well financially
or the whole ship sinks
but you have a beautiful film that wins
Sundance but it doesn't sell to a
distributor and it doesn't get out to an
audience or let's say it does get out to
an audience but they don't think it's
that beautiful because they're not a
cinephile they like movies that they can
turn their brain off a little bit and
just enjoy
and then they live with that film for
years and years to come
what do you think has more of an impact
it's like that Masterpiece that one
Sundance that everyone in the industry
claims is the most beautiful film that
year
or that fast and furious film or Star
Wars film or Marvel film that you can
just enjoy and love and watch for your
kids and just have a good time and then
you can do the same thing with that same
film next year
which one has a greater impact I think
the film that has rewatchability and you
can enjoy
and you wanted to make your own version
yes I wanted to make my own version as
much as I could
and I feel like we accomplished that
it's a it's a tuner film set in Atlanta
you have an enormous collection of cars
you have car sequences that are extended
and longer for the car audience than it
should have been for example if you're
going to cut to the scene maybe you have
one two three car shots and then you go
into the scene I would take that and
turn that into 30 shots of cars and then
go into the scene
um
in hindsight right as you get better and
evolve you look at your past projects
and you're like man I wish I could have
done this better or oh I could have did
that better
but again it goes back to the filmmaker
you have to create
in that time and space that you're in
and do the best that you can can do in
that time with what you have
because if you don't then maybe the
opportunity and the timing leaves you
and you may not ever be able to create
it again because you waited to try and
make it perfect like there's certain
shots where it would have been nice to
have a a huge gimbal attached to a truck
and then you get those shots because the
shots would have been super steady
compared to a little more shakier
because you don't have the right gimbal
but that's the gimbal that you have for
that shot
so you use it and then you capture what
you capture
if you wait to procure that truck
what happens if you're not able to
procure that truck you're not able to
procure that gimbal something falls
through this actor that you shot all
these scenes with no longer can shoot
something else happens because life
happens
so when that energy consumes you and it
inspires you to do something you gotta
act in that moment because the moment
you second guess you start giving
yourself excuses on not doing it and a
lot of times you won't do it if you
don't act in that moment and it's sort
of like driving as well can't really you
got to just kind of if you're too
focused on being scared of something or
whatever you could actually end up
hurting yourself 100 percent
how many cars did you have in four
Amigos
man a lot
so we
s2000s
VW VOC what Volkswagen the Jettas uh NSX
supercharged brz's Chargers Porsches
um
of course STIs we had uh I don't think
we had a Corvette in this film
uh but we had an NSX racing down the
freeway
uh Mustangs gt350s 90s Supras 2020 uh
one Supras Mark Mark IV Mark V
um we you name it we've had it and the
only legendary really car in that list
that we kind of didn't have with within
the tuner space
uh was an RX7
so I I couldn't I couldn't procure that
and I wanted to but we had probably a
good
I want to say 40 cars
we had Lamborghinis a Lotus uh lotuses
ivoras uh
Aston Martin's we've had a little bit of
everything yeah
and how did you get these cars again you
you put out calls yeah so for months I
knew that we were going to film on a
specific date so about three four months
in advance
I would go to every car meet every big
car meets small car meat and I would get
emails and I would get contacts and this
goes back to me selling food in Hawaii
right I would just hustle and you'd have
people say no I'm not interested or
you're a weirdo or whatever and I would
approach everybody hey man I'm gonna
shoot this this film can I get your
contact you might want to be in it and I
would just compile this list over months
and then when it came time to shoot it
was like hey guys I'm shooting this is
what I'm kind of looking for do you have
it do you have it and because the car
community and car culture they're so
loving
they were able to embrace me and help
guide me uh and help me bring this film
to life
so yes so so some of them you gave them
the call time and they showed up and
they showed up and uh a lot of the cars
in the movie are real cars a lot of the
actors in the movie with the cars it's
their car oh okay and you know I I was
able to add them to the film and let
them be a part of film history uh so it
was nice and and you know in the sequel
if I get if I get to the opportunity to
make the sequel it Dives deeper into
tuner cars and it's one of those things
where
I just kind of wanted to give back to a
culture that gave me so much joy and
because I realized that there was a gap
there and we didn't have many tuner
films to watch
I created something for them to watch
where can we see it so four Amigos now
it's on Amazon Prime uh it's on tivot so
you can rent it I think uh for 4.99 or
3.99
um and then in a couple months it will
be on 2B TV great yeah excellent
what was the strategy you had before you
made your first movie and how did that
strategy change for your second film
okay
first movie it was just about getting it
out
and with the first movie you're like oh
this is going to be on Netflix it's
gonna you're so optimistic and you need
that optimistic to carry you through
your career
but the main thing about it was I had to
prove to myself that I can get it done
so the strategy on the first one there
was no strategy it was like hey let's
make this movie
so I made the movie and I kind of winged
it the whole movie was just winged I did
create a shot list and everything and
realized I didn't use anything on the
shot list so now I don't even create
shot lists uh I I look at the space that
I have available to me and then I shoot
accordingly so with the first film it
was just about making it right
with the second film
I knew that I went from step one if if
Rex Park was step one I knew four Amigos
was step 20. and I knew that's how I
wanted to take it
so I had to plan a little more
so first my thought process and I'll go
over through the whole the whole thought
process and let me just say this to any
filmmaker out there
your film
no matter if it has a million dollar
budget a zero dollar budget or five
hundred thousand dollar budget
associated with it your film will be
judged against other high-level
Hollywood films with massive budgets
with a talented crew it doesn't matter
it's always going to be judged against
that because the viewer that's what they
watch and that's what they know and
that's what they're used to so they're
always going to judge your film against
that so with four Amigos
I knew right away
I had to up my game
I had to get better and I had to do
better so first I wrote the script
that I broke down the scenes
then I applied locations to scenes then
I started getting the cast together
about who was going to play what
and then we we stretched it out right
so once we had all that in place I
procured locations I got insurance for
those locations when we shot because it
was a much greater film and then I got
the drivers the drivers came from my my
months and months and months of
procuring drivers emails their cars
listing that out and getting that email
list ready
then once all of that was planned I had
my Blackmagic I had my 24 through 105
mil lens I had my really powerful light
I had a shoulder rig and I had a Sheen
Weevil s gimbal that had no business
holding the Blackmagic pocket cinema
camera right it had it wasn't strong
enough
but it's what I had and it's what I used
so the shoulder rig was used for all and
this was a cheap sixty dollar eBay
shoulder rig that was used to shoot
all of the talking shots
everything else was all gimbal lighting
we had our crew we had the actors we had
the locations we had everything set and
then we just pounded away and shot and
shot and shot and shot now you have to
know that when you're shooting if you're
a filmmaker if you shoot 6K 3-1
you're going to run out of storage
really fast and then you have to ask
yourself how much storage do you have at
home to transfer your footage because
it's almost impossible for me anyways to
edit footage on an external hard drive
that's 6K raw go into your PC so because
I knew that I shot uh 6K
cropped uh at five to one so that gave
me a little bit of space took the bit
rate down a little bit and I had more
storage for the film
then as I shot scenes I would edit the
scenes as I shot
so anytime I had a day off if I shot on
a Sunday I would edit on a Saturday if I
shot on a Saturday I'd edit on a Sunday
and then that way as the film neared its
completion all the scenes were already
done and then I just had to put them in
their sequence
and then that allowed for efficiency
so then once all of that was shot you're
working on post-production now
let me say this
always know when it comes to film
visuals are what you see
sound is what you feel
so sound design is to me more important
than the visuals because you can shot
something that's shot excellent lit well
performance as well but if the audio is
not good it's almost unwatchable but if
you have a film where it's shot decent
but the audio is Sublime
you can watch it now if you can get both
kind of like the way Marvel films are
right they they have they're the top
tier films nowadays that we're just
spoiled with because we get so much from
them
they fuse the visuals with the sound and
then you get epicness like Titanic or or
you know E.T or something
so as an indie filmmaker
focus on your sound when you go into
post-production and then focus on your
color grade from scratch not using a Lut
because if you're just going to use a
Lut then you're almost cutting yourself
short when you can really go in in
customize and characterize that color
for your film
so once you focus on sound design
there's uh not say controversy some
people agree with this some people don't
agree with this I ADR all my films and
the reason why I ADR that is there's a
pro and con the con is you lose a little
bit of performance
the pro is you get that sound quality
that's just unmatched so I ADR all of my
films from scratch and I treat audio in
a film like I would a song where you
separate the stems and your vocals so
then you're able to control the
grasshopper noises the car driving by
the the bird flying by and the person
talking you're able to adjust Infuse all
of these sounds like a blanket compared
to recording which you captured from
film and just laying it on top of the
blanket like a sandwich there's a very
different audible experience that you
feel going that route
now because I ADR you lose a little bit
of performance but in quality you gain
five points and performance you lose two
points so you're still up three and for
me it's worth it because even when
you're on set you're not worried about
waiting for the sound guy to record the
sound or to adjust and get in place
because when you're doing indie films
it's all about time it's all about time
I don't even use the board that says
okay scene one take three I don't do any
of that because I know I'm going to ADR
and I know I'm going to do all the sound
in post I know what Clips are going well
so when I shoot I'm shooting as I'm
editing so I know exactly how I'm going
to edit the next shot so I don't I don't
have to do these long long takes so now
that all of that's edited in post you
got your sound design you got your audio
your color grades done now you have a
completed film
now once that's done somebody would say
well hey go get someone you trust to
watch it and get their feedback
I don't do that
because if I'm painting a picture I'm
not asking you to say hey should I add
this red color here nah I'm the one
painting right now it's different if you
have a hundred million dollar film you
got to make sure that the audience
receives it well so you can recoup that
money but
if you're self-financing
then
you almost have
this
promise to your inner self that like you
have to create what you see
so I don't wait for someone's approval
no agent no manager no casting director
no producer
no executive
to tell me that the Final Cut Is the
Final Cut
I don't wait for the approval to tell me
that I can go make it I just make it so
once I'm finished with the film and I
watch it I'll watch it with my brother
and I'll say okay
I'm kind of go over like okay no that
was good or if we if something is so
jarring after sitting it with it for six
months editing or three months we're
like all right we got to take that out
then yes we'll take it out but as far as
reshooting
um and just changing the whole feel of
the movie whatever comes over me as I'm
creating that's what the universe gave
me to paint and what it's said to do at
that time because you got to remember
like when you create a film it's your
film
it's not Johnny's Vision because if it
was Johnny's Vision then Johnny would go
right and create that film it's your
vision so be confident and comfortable
with what you create and know that it's
okay it's okay for you to create it's
okay for you to be great it's okay for
you to be the best version of yourself
it's okay to be happy it's okay for you
to mess up it's okay to to not succeed
on your first try it's okay to get up
after you got knocked down it's okay to
fail it's okay to succeed it's okay to
be who you are as a human being it's
okay and film is not the end-all be-all
life goes on Beyond film
film is what you do film is what you
create film is the the piece of you that
you give out to the world but film is
not who you are
I love that I love too that you said
that it's okay to succeed because I
think sometimes people feel guilty
yeah you don't feel like sometimes
you're good enough you don't feel
confident in yourself
to say
I can be successful too
I can do what Spielberg did I can be
that too
and I think you know when they talk
about like something like imposter
syndrome or anything like that like no
it's it's okay to be like yeah I can
make movies I can do it well
I I can do
what they can do at a high level I can
do that it's okay because cocky is only
cocky if you're not able to back it up
confidence is knowing that you already
did it and you can do it again and
you're going to need confidence to get
you where your vision is at because a
vision is only you seeing what is
possible if you stick to the plan and
you go and get after it that's all it is
so
when I say hey it's okay
it's okay to love yourself right it's
okay to like yourself it's okay to uh
appreciate what you accomplish like
there's a lot of times where somebody
would say
wow man you did an incredible job
and my response used to be
oh thanks man I'm just trying to get
like you but that's such a
response because in reality your
response it's okay to be like thank you
I put a lot of work I put a lot of
effort into that thank you I I
appreciate that you acknowledge that
thank you compared to not letting
yourself
enjoy that praise not to say to get full
of yourself but when someone compliments
you on your work it's okay to accept it
and not have to deflect it it's okay to
be great it's okay like I don't think we
hear that enough it's okay hey if you're
not good enough at something right now
put the effort in to get better and be
good enough but you don't have to be
good enough to someone else you have to
be good enough to yourself
so when you look in the mirror and
you're like man I'm happy with what I
see then you've succeeded in life
and that goes back to film it's like hey
you're good enough just keep swinging
how do you prepare for a production day
when you're wearing so many hats you're
the producer director lead actor and
cinematographer the only thing I prepare
is getting everybody there
right there's no shot list there's
nothing I own all the equipment I own
all the gear I know how to work it I
know how to operate it I know what I'm
trying to capture in the lens because
the only thing I'm concerned about is
what's seen within that frame
so if I can get everyone there
I can move mountains
so the way I break it down is it's three
stages when you think about
filming and then final product
pre-production creating it words lining
everything up getting everyone ready
production the fun part everyone gets to
create have a good time you get to shoot
all that stuff post production
you do all the the the color grading
editing ADR sound design music score
everything and then yeah the fourth
phase which is selling distribution all
of that stuff and getting it out to the
world marketing
so when it comes to shooting on set
I break things down in a very easy
strategic way that's not only efficient
but it takes the pressure off of the
actors and actresses
it allows for the freedom of creativity
and it's easier on myself and my brother
so when I'm in front of the camera
I'll set up the shot set up the light
put at the focal length that I want
and then I'll hand it out to my brother
my brother will go and I'm like okay
here move the camera here do this and
then he'll go in and do that stuff so
he's been a tremendous help in allowing
me to be in front of the camera and
still capture what I need to capture
by breaking it down into segments and
instead of taking this whole page as
this one scene you take a whole page and
break it down into four segments right
now it's like hey
as an actor you only have to worry about
these three lines right now this is what
we're going to shoot
and instead of them having to do nine
lines they did three lines okay now
we're going to cut to this because I
shoot as an editor
that saves me so much time and space
because I don't get anything that I
don't need
the moment we get to take I know that's
the take I'm going to use to edit I move
on
I adjust the lights where I need it to
be and then we shoot in sequence so even
when I edit
I know that the sequence is going in
line with the scene so if I'm shooting
line 27
we start at the beginning of 27.
and we shoot that in sequence then as we
shoot that and we get you know closer to
me being on camera because I tend to
shoot everyone else first
I get all their shots first and then I
shoot my sequence my sequences are a lot
quicker because I already kind of know
what I want to do with the character and
I my shots are less magical because
they're a lot more mechanical
here's the thing
I'm not the best actor right I would say
I'm probably like an average actor if
across the board I'm just average don't
I can do everything except Cry On Cue
like I've tried cutting onions I've
tried sticks I just can't cry I don't
know what it is I just can't cry but I
can do everything else
so when it comes to me being on camera I
know what looks good I know it sounds
good I know that if we're shooting close
up don't move your head too much you
know if you're gonna do action shots
we're gonna go a little wider
I get that so once I shoot everybody
else first and we've captured all of
their sauce because I'm so
um
aware of their time
that when it comes to me I do my takes
in about one or two takes and then we
move on
and I know that
now that I've said this on camera you
might be able to tell that okay he did
that like I wanted to takes because we
have to keep moving we have to keep
going and when you wear so many hats you
have to get out of your head that this
is stressful it's not like you're making
a movie
you're setting people up you're setting
the lighting and you're pushing record
if this is what you want to do with your
life then it's fun time
so take away the stress because you are
what you think
so if you think making a movie is going
to be hard it's going to be hard but I
can tell you it's not hard it's time
consuming anything in life it's not hard
you're not out there drilling oil in the
middle of the ocean you're making a
movie
so if you can break it down into steps
and just be consistent filmmaking will
be a lot easier than you think it is
Hollywood likes to to give you the magic
and show you there's a hundred people on
set and that it's super difficult like
yeah to make
Hollywood's budget films Hollywood level
films you have Masters at each section
Masters at lighting Masters at
cinematography Focus polling directors
you got these Masters so they're coming
out with the master product
you as an indie filmmaker you don't have
those Masters on your team a lot of the
times so you have to wear a lot of hats
you have to become the master
what that does is you trim the fat you
know how to streamline your movement and
you learn how to get things done but if
you learn how to direct and edit at the
same time your editing becomes so much
easier and it becomes
a lot more feasible and consumable to
digest the entirety of a film you edit
your films as well yes okay so I edit my
films uh a lot of times as I'm shooting
um with pizza boy Rick I wanted to do it
a little different so I'm shooting first
and then I I'm starting the editing
process I like to try different things
to kind of see what works for me but
when it comes to editing there's
two things that I really that I focus on
as I'm editing uh you're scrubbing
through the footage you're seeing what
you want you're kind of going for a
particular look so that's your color
grade from scratch
and it doesn't have to be anything fancy
you don't need 10 layers you can color
it to get it to look good and then
decide if you want to go a little warm a
little cool you want to just keep it
neutral different scenes can kind of
look differently depending on where
you're at
the biggest thing about post-production
and editing is sound design like I can't
stress enough how important sound is
because
when I say you feel sound it's so true
when I say okay look we're gonna edit
I'm gonna take these 10 takes and I'm
going to edit it into the most dynamic
scene that I possibly can edit and
there's a lot of times where I see a
scene and I'm like man I wish I would
have did that differently because I only
give myself so many takes and because
you wear so many hats you don't have the
luxury of really thinking oh I'm gonna
do this with this character no because
it's like all right I'm directing okay
get in this goodness okay my turn action
then you go so when I am editing there's
a lot of times where as a actor right
taking off the other hats as an actor
I would have performed it maybe a little
different I would have let myself get
into that zone just a little bit more
but as a filmmaker
I'm like it's fine let's move on so
because I'm able to see that take and
I'm able to see it in the final timeline
on how I'm going to edit it what the
color grade is going to look like how is
it going to turn out what is it going to
sound like
the editing process
becomes the most enjoyable part about
the film because that's where it really
comes to live uh comes alive if you
think about any film that you love
that's just incredible to you
there's probably one or two things I'm
gonna say two things that I can
guarantee exists with any film that
anyone loves
sound design
music
and the reason why that's so important
is because they give you a Feeling
to a specific time and place
like I love 80s 90s music scores that's
what I love because that's what I grew
up with and for me those are kind of
Timeless scores right when you're
talking music
if
you're someone newer
you might like the early 2000s
scores because those are a part of you
at a certain time in life right so
if you think about like I don't listen
to music that much anymore as I've
gotten older
all of the music that I listen to almost
stopped when I was like 2019 but that's
because in those times a lot of the
music is associated with things that
I've experienced for the first time
so then as you get older and you don't
experience things for the first time
anymore it doesn't have that same memory
impact
so
as a filmmaker
when you're in post-production or you're
thinking about how you want a shot to be
completed think of your sound think of
how you're going to do your sound design
so in my films a lot of times there's
not empty spaces where there's this
dialogue and the reason for that is
because I enjoy sound so much I want it
to be
almost like its own experience
throughout the story that if you could
turn off the dialogue and just hear the
sonic waves going without them talking
you can still get a sense of what's
happening in the film
so that's why sound design is so
important when you're in post-production
and shooting and editing at the same
time is extremely important as a
filmmaker especially if you're in front
of the camera
um
because it allows you to know exactly
what you're trying to capture and you
don't have to guess and then you don't
have to go through terabytes of footage
to try and just get that perfect shot
do you ever wish though like when you
get it in the editing Bay or excuse me
on the timeline like I wish I had one
more take of this all the time oh okay
all the time especially like
when you have Dynamic shots
um car shots
me in front of the camera
I always know especially in hindsight
right because when you're editing it's
almost hindsight like you've already
shot it so now you're editing
I always
as a creator
know that I can do it better
the moment it's done I know I can do it
better the moment where I'm like all
right it's a wrap I know I can make that
movie better because I just gained all
of that experience points I just leveled
up I just became better because I just
did another project
um so there's certain things that you
see when you're in editing that you
don't necessarily see on set because
you're thinking of five steps ahead or
even when you look at the shot you're
like yeah it looks great and then when
you look at it on a big screen you're
like uh that could have been focused a
little better or this person I didn't
see that soda can back there right you
miss those things sometimes
um but it's just it's it's all part of
the the
evolution of you as an artist it's all
part of
what you do when you make films you're
always going to look at something and
say I could have done that better